Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, wie viele Regierungsprojekte wurden diese Woche jetzt noch mal gehackt?
Fünf.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer 421 vom 11. Februar zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Wo wir bei dem Thema fünf sind, Tim, ne? Ich war äh in in der Sea Base kürzlich hm Sea Bay Sticker Kiste geguckt.
Da gab's einen äh gibt's da eine äh Aufkleberserie,
äh mit Blockchain Memes ja äh
so Clubhouse in der Blockchain, Cyberinnovation, in der Blockchain und ein Aufkleber, wo äh hier so ein Face Palm-Emoji drauf ist und da drunter steht einfach nur fünf Blockchains.
Natürlich in der korrekten Schreibweise und
hatte Marie mir schon von den Stickern erzählt letztes Jahr, dass sie die macht. Ich hatte das ja irgendwie vergessen, habe dann einige davon mal getwittert
und habe getwittert, wer von euch war das? Es dauerte nicht lange bis dann natürlich rauskam, wer es war. Ja und äh,
habe mich dann doch sehr also ist natürlich schon lustig wenn du irgendwie Sticker von deinem eigenen Meme irgendwie entdeckst in einer Stickerkiste, von denen du gar nicht wusstest, dass es sie gibt. Aber Tim.
Außerdem wurde mir verraten, dass wir welche per Post bekommen haben in die Metaebene. Das heißt, du hast die und du hast sie mir nicht gegeben.
Hier ist nichts angekommen, also zumindest nicht erfolgreich.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Ich ich hörte da auch was von Lebkuchen. Äh den ich nie bekommen habe. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie das da mit dieser 3D verliert der Postbote aber relativ oft irgendwie die die guten Sachen, die kommen immer nicht an.
Die Lebkuchen, die gehen durch durch den Kinderfilter und äh die Aufkleber weiß ich nicht, sind wahrscheinlich schon vorher geklaut worden mir ausm Briefkasten.
So sieht das aus.
HTTP Status.
Ja
Status. Vielleicht noch mal kurz gleich äh vorne weg. Äh wie schon in den letzten beiden Sendungen haben wir auch dieses Mal.
Moin moin. Auch du äh hattest Spaß mit äh Blockchains und das hat uns äh gleich motiviert, dich mal mit äh an Bord zu holen. Aber bevor wir auf dich eingehen,
müssen wir noch kurz die Statusfrage klären,
nichts damit zu tun, dass wir jetzt.
Vergessen haben oder so was, sondern es gibt da zwar so Statuskurse, aber die sind nicht so richtig offiziell und mit sowas geben wir uns gar nicht erst ab. Aber mit vierhunderteinundzwanzig geht's tatsächlich wieder weiter. Vierhunderteinundzwanzig ist nämlich der schöne.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch ganz kurz betonen, ne, dass wir es ja auch geschafft haben, die Sendung von,
twenty durchzuhalten, ohne einen einzigen for twenty Witz.
Durch komm gib's zu. Wir haben's einfach verpeilt.
Wir waren so bekifft.
Mitbekommen.
Nicht ungültig, also es sind sagen wir mal, die sind undefiniert sind aber dann von irgendwelchen Fremdworks gekappert worden, die der Meinung sind, sie bräuchten jetzt mal ihren eigenen Statuscode und haben dann einfach die genommen,
natürlich auch ein ganz schlechter Stil ist in gewisser Hinsicht ähm aber äh so ist das Internet halt auch, ne. Also wenn du da nicht aufpasst und die alle wegschließt, dann dann dann,
machen die alle nur Ärger. Na ja, auf jeden Fall 4hundert1und2 hat den schönen Namen Mister Rected request.
Man kann jetzt wirklich aus jedem dieser Status-Kurs kann man halt irgendwie so einen so einen so einen lustigen Politwitz machen. Das klingt halt immer alles nach Fail. Vielleicht ein bisschen albern, ne, auch wenn ich immer so dieses Gefühl habe, Thilo Jung fragt grade den Regierungssprecher wieder irgendwas.
Und kriege dann immer so diesen kann sich jemand anders fragen, ich kann das nicht mehr antworten, ich will das nicht beantworten, ich darf das nicht beantworten so einen Blick.
Ja, ist so einer der neueren äh Statuscodes. Ist auch genauso unaufregend wie die letzten äh schon und regelt halt einfach so dieses äh probier's mal. Probier's mal aufm anderen Weg, vielleicht irgendwie.
Hatte die P zwei oder was weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Du kannst einfach was sagen. Du musst nicht vorher tippen, so, ich möchte, du musst dich nicht melden, du darfst was äh.
Äh alle.
Meinungsfreiheit. Was uns nicht gefällt, schneiden wir raus.
Alles gut. Ich dachte, ihr wollt äh erst die Vorstellungsrunde machen.
Nein, nein, nein, sag.
Hast du eine Meinung zum HTTP-Status? Das ist die Frage.
Ja ja, also,
Ihr habt jetzt noch die Gelegenheit by the way äh bei der IITF noch Einreichung zu machen für die April Fools äh die veröffentlichen ja immer am ersten April so so lustige äh Quatsch-Standards.
Gab es übrigens auch mal den Vorschlag, ein Joint Roating Protokoll einzureichen. Das hat es aber nie geschafft, weil die, keine Ahnung, einen Stock im Arsch haben oder so bei der AETF.
Also noch habt ihr die Gelegenheit und könnt euch da vielleicht auch einfach noch so ein HTTP-Status krallen.
Wollen wir's mit Podcast sozusagen.
Hm.
Kannst du allen möglichen was machen. Also ich hatte überlegt irgendwie diesen Mast-Schutz-Kurt äh RFC zu nehmen und da äh Emojis mit reinzubauen, weil äh Emojis sind natürlich cool und dann kann man irgendwie
kurz irgendwie so in so Truck oder.
Mhm.
Okay ähm.
Äh jetzt aber siehst du, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir's versaut, Tim. Was? Also zwei vier zwanzig äh vier einundzwanzig ist Mister request und der ist bei aber das ist ein HTTP zwei.
Wurde sozusagen mit HTP zwei kam der sozusagen neu äh dazu und ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz genau, aber ich glaube, das ist so dieses so, wenn du nur das eine Protokoll unterstützt, dann,
sagen so ja nee nimm mal das andere, was weiß ich. Ist ja auch alles total unspannend,
Haben wir das angekündigt, dass wir alle Status kurz vorstellen, dann machen wir das natürlich auch. Was weiß ich, vielleicht können später die Krypto- und Exchanges, die ihre Kohle, ihre Bitcoins geklaut bekommen haben können, mit dem Status Quo dann irgendwie,
auffordern, ja Bitcoins zurückzugeben oder so was.
Das Geld ist nicht weg, es ist nur woanders.
Dazu später noch mehr.
Ja Flippke, jetzt mal zu dir. Ähm was bist du denn äh für ein dahergelaufener schmutziger TCC-Hacker? Ähm gehört du gehörst zu dieser Zusammenrottung.
Ja, so so sieht das aus, wenn man so dieser Ersatz und der Kommunikation äh von denen zum,
in die Bundeskanzleramt war's äh glauben darf.
Ja, ich bin so ein digital Disabler und zusammen mit Lilit äh spiele ich ganz gerne so Blockchain-Projekte der Bundesregierung oder Bundesregierungsnahen Institutionen,
und so auch diese Woche mal wieder.
Wobei man hier tatsächlich mal wieder äh schon sagen muss, ich meine, wir hatten schon die ID-Wallet äh kaputtgespielt. Das war eine etwas aufwendigere ähm Analyse im Vergleich zu dem, was wir jetzt hier gemacht haben und,
ansonsten bin ich nicht immer so
ganz so destruktiv unterwegs in meiner Freizeit. Äh manche kennen mich vielleicht von der Flip-Dot-Installation aufm Kongress, die ich gebaut hatte.
Die lieben meine Gäste übrigens, ne? Ich habe die ja ich habe ja in ich habe ja auch einen Flip Dot von dir
und ähm das benutze ich als äh Standard äh Display der der Information, die man so braucht äh und eine davon ist die Uhrzeit, sodass das Ding jede Minute einmal so.
Sehr gut. Äh nur ganz nebenbei, ich habe keine mehr. Also wenn jetzt Leute irgendwie glauben, äh ich ich habe wirklich keine mehr. Also äh.
Oh nein, echt nicht?
Alle weg.
Boah, okay, ich ich hätte nämlich echt gerne noch eins äh gebraucht, ja.
Man könnte mal bei bei anderen ähm Verkehrsbetrieben anfragen, aber BVG ist auf jeden Fall jetzt ausverkauft. Die sind jetzt komplett auf LED umgestiegen.
Bevor wir hier zu Insider-mäßig äh rumgehen, also was das.
Müsse erklären, was das war.
Genau, also Flip-Dop-Displays sind ja diese alten digital Matrix
die man eben unter anderem in Busanzeigen gesehen hat, noch bevor das alles äh auf LED oder andere Leuchtmittel umgeschaltet wurde, das sind diese Dinger, die halt einfach mechanisch umklappen, die so magnetisch gehalten werden, wo da so in der in der Mitte schräg der Pixel äh umklappt
und äh dann bleibt das dann sozusagen auch so, was diese wunderbaren Update-Geräusche auch erzeugt und.
Sehr, sehr energiesparsam die Dinger tatsächlich im Vergleich zu den LEDs, weil sie halt äh den Zustand so von alleine halten können.
Problem mit den Dingern ist, dass sie relativ anfällig sind und das hat man ja auch auf der äh Kongressinstallation gesehen, so die sind halt anfällig für UV-Strahlung und dadurch, dass sie mechanisch sind, gehen sie halt doch
mal kaputt.
Und du hast dir damals, äh das musst du schon noch kurz erzählen, die Flip-Dot-Installation. Du hast dir damals von der BVG eine größere Menge dieser Dinger, äh die offenbar aus den Trams rausgepult wurden, gesichert, ne?
Genau, so sieht's aus. Also ähm ich dachte mir, cool, so Flip Dots äh habe ich schon häufiger mal irgendwie drüber nachgedacht, ob man da irgendwie drankommt und das ja immer irgendwie bisschen schwierig an so was halt dranzukommen. Also habe ich äh bei der BVG einfach mal angefragt, ob
die was haben und tatsächlich haben welche. Erstmal nur so zehn Stück gekauft und äh reverse engineer, bisschen äh Hardware für entwickelt. Übrigens auch so eine Sache, die ich ganz gerne in meiner Freizeit mache,
Hardwareentwicklung und dann äh da fällt wie gesagt eine Ansteuerung gebaut,
dann eine größere Menge bei der BVGäh gekauft und dann war die Überlegung hm wie bekomme ich die jetzt irgendwie an die Leute verteilt die zu verschicken mit der DHL ist irgendwie ziemlich teuer, das kostet irgendwie 40 Euro das Stück,
blöd, okay, dann schleppe ich die halt irgendwie einfach alle zum Kongress mit und verteile die da in irgendwelche Huckerspaces. Hm, aber dann habe ich aufm Kongress ja irgendwie so hundert Flap,
da könnte man ja irgendwie was draus machen und dann ist dieser Aspe,
eigentlich in irgendwelche Leute verteilen wollte, so komplett in den Hintergrund gerückt und äh die Idee entstanden, da eine Kunstinstallation daraus zu bauen. Ähm zunächst sollte das eigentlich eine andere Installation werden. Es sollte eigentlich einen äh runder Turm werden, wo ich den,
Hexaggune immer weiter übereinander stecke, bis ich halt keine funktionierenden mehr habe. Ähm aber am Ende ist es dann eine Wand um äh so eine Verkleidung, um so eine Bühne drumherum geworden
und da könnt ihr euch dann äh ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viele Pixel das waren. Es waren auf jeden Fall sehr sehr viele und es hat sehr viel Strom äh in der Spitze gebraucht. Ähm,
darstellen.
Wir haben mal in die Show-Notes einen Link, aber so richtig geil dokument
also im Sinne von wenn man der Code ist ja dokumentiert ist ja alles auf GTA aber so mal so schöne Videos wie das Ding in voller Pracht da äh vor sich hinballert ähm gab's nicht so wirklich mehr, ne? Ich ich finde auf jeden Fall keine geilen.
Darstellung, die das so in der,
in in dem in der Schönheit wiedergeben, wie ich es äh äh in in Erinnerung habe.
Ja, ich hatte leider keine gute Kamera mit dabei, um das irgendwie zu dokumentieren. Ähm hat aber ein paar Freunde gebeten, das zu dokumentieren, Tabak noch ein bisschen Material hier. Äh die Kunst und Selektion an sich könnte vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen äh besser äh dokumentieren, was ich da gebaut habe.
Jedenfalls die Hardware und Software an sich sind relativ gut dokument.
Auch wenn das eher so ein Hass-Thema ist, was ich nicht so gerne mache, so Dokumentationsschreiben ähm vor allem bei irgend so einem Freizeit.
Und vielleicht werden wir das jetzt auch demnächst nochmal sehen äh diese äh Flip Dots, die sind jetzt nicht äh irgendwo verschwunden und in eine Kiste gesteckt worden, sondern die liegen jetzt gerade beim
KM so und äh werden da auf jeden Fall noch ein weiteres Leben haben.
Ach so, also du hast quasi nicht äh nicht in einzelnen verkauft, sondern oder abgegeben, sondern die die sind jetzt irgendwo in in in äh als als Rudel. Okay, sehr gut. Da bin ich beruhigt.
Habe jemanden äh vom ZKM gefunden, der da auch schon zuvor mit anderen Flip Dot Displays Dinge gebaut hat und das war dann für mich äh sehr viel unkomplizierter. Die äh en Bike äh jemanden in die Hand drücken zu können.
Wollte gerade sagen, weil die in Einzelteilen.
Es waren äh100 Stück und ich habe noch mal eine Fuhre von der BVG bekommen, die sie eigentlich als Ersatzteile vorrätig gehalten haben.
Die haben die Trams äh also sie haben irgendwelche alten Tatra-Trans äh verkauft nach Osteuropa und haben äh andere äh,
und deswegen durfte ich dann nochmal ein paar haben, aber jetzt sind sie tatsächlich äh aus. Also haben sie keine mehr.
War auf jeden Fall eine super Installation, ein bester Blinkenlids-Manier, auch so mit so einem.
Danke, danke.
Mit so einem schönen Trash äh Aspekt dabei und äh das war auch echt eins der künstlerischen Highlights auf dem äh Kongress, das kann man schon sagen.
Nicht das einzige, aber auf jeden Fall eins davon.
Ja ich werde auf jeden Fall sehr nice wie irgendwie das äh Infrarot äh wie man unter dem nee nicht Infrarot, wie man unterm UV so den den Burn-In sehen konnte, dass die halt schon alt sind und äh halt sehr viel,
tausende, wenn nicht Millionen Kilometer irgendwie durch durch Berlin gefahren.
Also muss man vielleicht erklären, das ist ja eine eine Neonfarbe,
äh und die also diese was heißt Neon? Was ist das? Phospieren,
eigentlich, ne,
Das heißt, wird dann mit mit UV-Licht angestrahlt, dann dann leuchten die besonders, aber natürlich dieser diese UV-Phosforcierende Farbe lässt natürlich nach und äh da wo dann halt, das weiß man eben von welcher
das Ding ungefähr war oder zumindest dort wo das wo das Tramlogo ist sieht man dass dort die Pixe mehr,
gezeigt wurden, als jetzt zum Beispiel die am oberen Rand, die ja selten äh zum Beispiel angesprochen werden. Ist auch bei mir so, wenn wenn äh die Beleuchtung in dem Zimmer, wo ich die, wo ich das Flip dort habe, blau ist, dann wird das Ding auf einmal ganz unregelmäßig, weil die eben
unterschiedliche äh Exposur zu Sonnenlicht hatten. Ja schönes Ding.
Kommen wir zu weniger schönen Dingen.
Ja kommen wir zum Kaputtmachen. Also du hast jetzt quasi deinen kreativen Geist äh unter Beweis gestellt. Den musste ich jetzt nicht mehr äh verteidigen oder äh Angriffen ausgesät sind. Wir können jetzt einfach uns endlich dem,
der Zerstörung widmen.
Wie kam's denn dazu?
Ähm wie's dazu kam. Ich hatte schon zuvor von diesem äh Zeugnisprojekt gehört und ich glaube,
Iso Top hatte, was äh fett twittert, wo über dieses Projekt berichtet wurde und da war ein Link drinnen, den packe ich auch mal in die äh,
wo man dann irgendwie so Zeugnisse verifizieren können sollte und der war tot, der hat nicht funktioniert. Also habe ich einfach mal eine E-Mail geschrieben und gefragt, hey Leute, wie sieht's denn eigentlich aus, wo kann man sich das Ganze mal angucken und dann habe ich eine Antwort bekommen. Mit einem Link drinne, wo man dann irgendwie so Zeugnisse,
PDFs hochladen könnt. Ähm da stand auch nicht dran, dass es irgendein Testsystem oder so was ist, sondern ähm wie sich auch
Bei äh aus einer IFG-Anfrage herausstellte. Das ist ein abgeschlossenes,
zu sein. Das ist ein Testsystem oder sowas.
Uns ist nicht sonderlich lange angeguckt, so anderthalb, zwei Stunden haben wir da mal gegengetreten,
haben dabei äh so ein, zwei Sachen gesehen.
Das eine war eine Cross-Side-Scripting-Attacke und das andere waren ähm Daten, die sie in dem System gespeichert haben. Okay und noch eine Sache ähm und zwar
konnte man dort äh Zeugnisse sich rendern lassen als PDF.
Ähm da muss man allerdings fairerweise dazu sagen, dass die nicht signiert waren und auch nicht in der Blockchain da verankert waren.
Aber wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, wenn du jetzt da irgendwie so ein hübsches Zeugnis produzierst, wo irgendwie
Bundesdruckerei drauf, draufsteht und das alles irgendwie so hochoffiziell aussieht und du irgendjemanden dieses Zeugnis in die Hand drückst und sagst, guck mal hier, Abiturzeugnis äh digital und dann probiert irgendjemand das zu verifizieren und dann sagt die Kiste, ja nee, ist ungültig
glaubt, dass die Technik einfach noch nicht fertig ist und einfach nicht funktioniert oder dass das Zeugnis tatsächlich gefälscht ist so. Also.
Vielleicht mal aus deiner Perspektive schildern, was das System eigentlich tun soll.
Ja das frage ich mich auch so ein bisschen, was für ein Problem da eigentlich gelöst werden soll. Also,
riecht so ein bisschen so wie äh wir haben hier so ein so ein so eine Technologie und die wollen wir jetzt irgendwie verkaufen. So so erscheint mir das irgendwie. Ähm also die Idee von dem ganzen Projekt ist irgendwie, dass man
Zeugnisse, äh fälschungssicher macht, weil ihr kennt es ja, Zeugnisse werden immer gefälscht und
Sind ja auch der einzige Weg, um irgendwie sicher zu sein, dass jetzt eine Bewerber in irgendwie Ahnung hat.
Und die sollen jetzt fälschungssicher gemacht werden so. Das ist ja eigentlich,
gelöstes Problem. Es gibt Dinge wie Signaturverfahren und so ähm aber in irgendeiner komischen, interessanten äh.
Argumentationskette sind sie dann dazu gekommen, dass es dafür unbedingt Blockchain braucht.
Es ist so, wir haben das ja, wir haben das ja hier schon schon vor ein paar Monaten mal besprochen, als diese Idee aufkam, ne, also du hast es auch gerade gesagt. Und vor allem, was ich nicht verstehe, ist, warum ausgerechnet die Bundesdruckerei noch auf die Idee kommt, ja, weil wie du gerade schon sagst, man würde halt einfach ein paar
eine schöne PKI machen, ein paar CAs, ja und dann könntest du das halt könntest du halt Zeugnisse,
ja, dann würde man sich im Gegensatz
wie man's bei den Impfzertifikaten gemacht hat, sogar noch eine Revocation dazu machen,
so in in völlig mutiger Überspezifikation,
Was wirklich irgendwie nicht nachvollziehbar ist so, warum soll es eine Blockchain haben? Also.
Welchen was was also.
Na ja also.
Ich habe letzte Woche auf der IT-Security Conference einen kleinen äh Blockchain-Vortrag gehalten,
den ich sicherlich auch irgendwann noch einmal öffentlich halten werde und da äh hatte ich dieses schöne Zitat und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo ich's herhatte, wenn ein Buzzword oft genug gesagt wurde, wird es zum Budget,
dann ist das halt so, ne? Dann hast du halt nur ein Budget für Blockchain und dann musst du halt Zeugnisse der Blockchain machen. Aber warum ausgerechnet die Bundesdruckerei, ja, die ja wirklich ein Abonnement auf,
Bundesaufträge hat, die jetzt halt mit PKI ja durchaus auch Erfahrung hat,
Ja? Warum ausgerechnet die sagt, wir machen Zeugnisse in der Blockchain und also was sollte das sollen, ja? Also ich ich verstehe es nicht, wenn äh also.
Und Punkt ist auch die äh Bundesdruckerei, die,
betreibt ja sogar eine CA, die in eurem Betriebssystem sehr wahrscheinlich sogar mit drinnen ist und und getrastet ist, dass das so ein Laden, der halt eigentlich Trust-Dienstleistungen verkauft, sich mit äh sondern komplett unreifen,
komplett unfertigen Lösung irgendwie
und äh auf der einen Seite dieses unfertige Scheißding hat und auf der anderen Seite irgendwie eine CA aus äh betreibt, die in eurem Betriebssystem einfach mal drinnen ist. Also es passt einfach nicht aneinander, finde ich.
Es ist ja nicht nur unfertig, es ist vor allem sinnlos. Ich glaube, wir müssen mal kurz den Buzzword äh
äh Level ein bisschen äh runterschrauben, um mal kurz zu dekodieren, äh was hier eigentlich die Situation ist. Also wir haben diese Bundesdruckerei, die also ein bisschen so so ein halböffentliches Ding irgendwie ist so. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sind dir jetzt so die Besitzverhältnisse? Wie privat ist denn die Bundesdruckerei jetzt eigentlich gerade?
Staatsunternehmen, also die sind privat, aber gehören dem Staat.
Ich gucke einfach mal kurz äh nach, weil äh so was sollten wir wissen.
Sagen wir mal so, die Gewinne sind privat und der Rest des,
so könnte man das wahrscheinlich in der Regel ganz gut zusammenfassen, oder?
Also genau, sie waren nämlich privatisiert und ist 2009 wieder zurückgekauft worden,
Ne, das das das ist ihnen ja schon mal entglitten. Das das war ja der der eigentliche Aufreger.
Und äh das hat man dann dann doch irgendwie gemerkt, dass es doch eine Scheißidee ist, jetzt irgendwie ausgerechnet das Unternehmen, was so hochgradig mit der Security von Geld und,
Dokumenten und so weiter beschäftigt ist und dazu halt theoretisch zumindest auch noch so ein Kompetenzzentrum ist für äh digitale Angelegenheiten. Ich meine, so viele haben wir jetzt nicht.
Ja und äh auch in der Hinsicht bekleckern die sich jetzt auch grade nicht mit Rum. So, also das ist jetzt erst mal als erstes so und jetzt,
die sozusagen etabliert und wie du schon so schön sagst, sie sie haben selber so eine CA, das heißt sie sind quasi als Zertifizierungsautorität, das heißt ja CA anerkannt und damit verbreitet und könnten jetzt im Prinzip,
ohne irgendein neues Projekt aufzusetzen, einfach ein beliebiges Dokument nehmen,
wie zum Beispiel ein Zeugnis, nur mal so als Beispiel, ja und das einfach digital signieren mit ihrer Zertifikatsautorität,
dann steht das da drin und dann glaubt das jeder der,
quasi generell dieser Zertifikatsautorität Bundesdruckerei, die also halbwegs offiziell ist äh vertraut. So und wenn du der nicht vertraust, na ja dann vertraust du halt.
Nicht so deine eigene Entscheidung, aber wenn du dem vertraust, dann vertraust du indirekt damit eben auch,
eben diese Entität oder die Identität, die jetzt vielleicht die Bundesdruckerei äh als,
Hier ist das neue Zeugnis Beglaubigungsinstitut der Bundesrepublik Deutschland äh in Kraft gesetzt hat, dass man dem dann halt glaubt, weil das eben entsprechend unterschrieben, unterschrieben, unterschrieben ist,
fertig aus die Laube. Also wenn man sozusagen Zeugnisse,
Digital,
Sitzen jetzt irgendwas auf und es heißt dann irgendwie was mit Blockchain und wir ahnen's halt schon, warum sie das tun,
Weil's irgendwie alle anderen auch sagen
Es ist einfach so ein Halbwort geworden, wie alle vor 30 Jahren rannten sie alle über die Messen und wir so ja äh,
Wir sind jetzt open. Ja was heißt das? Ja äh wissen wir ja auch nicht genau, aber wir sind jetzt irgendwie open. So ne, die die.
Du musst halt Ökosystem denken.
Ja, also es ist halt immer irgend so ein so ein so ein Buzzword, was einfach gerade wieder äh,
durch die ganze Wirtschaft durchzuckt und dann halt irgendwann so oft mantramäßig repetiert wird bis das dann irgendwie von allen so als wichtig angesehen wird. Ich meine klingt ja so ein bisschen,
lustig formuliert, aber ich glaube genauso ist das. Ja, also alle wiederholen das.
Und irgendwann glauben Sie sich auch alle selbst, dass es irgendwie wichtig ist, weil sich gar keiner mehr traut in so einer Umgebung zu sagen, dass es nicht wichtig ist.
Ich habe mal eine Frage.
Da gibt es äh so ein so ein Webtool und da lädst du dann dein das
PDF rein und das popelt dann aus den PDFs und XML-Datei raus und ähm prüft dann mit dieser XML-Datei, ob da äh ob das in der
irgendwie mitverankert ist. Also die Idee ist da wohl ein Hash irgendwie zu bilden. Wir konnten uns den Blockchain-Partner von tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so viel genau angucken.
Weil die Blockchain privat ist, ne.
Das ist eine private Blockchain, aber es gibt einen,
Ja, also es gibt einen Block Explorer, damit kann man äh da reingucken, was da für Transaktionen drinnen laufen. Damit konnten wir auch die anderen Instituten finden, die irgendwie an diesem,
teilnehmen. Fun Fact Lilit und ich haben mehr Institutionen testweise erstellt als Diebes.
Und haben da einfach mal äh quatschen die Blockchain auch reingeschrieben.
Flipke und Lilit waren hier.
Ja und äh.
Der.
Man konnte da so so so äh auf jeden Fall Quatschtext reinladen ähm und,
Lustige ist, dass man nicht direkt mit der Blockchain interagiert, sondern durch so eine total tolle Javanwendung. Das heißt
man könnte auch einfach das Ding nehmen, wie es ist. This back and austauschen durch
irgendwas mit einer Postrestdatenbank oder keine Ahnung was für eine no sequal Hipster-Daten macht und könnte halt exakt den gleichen Service darstellen nach außen. Zumal die meisten Leute äh wahrscheinlich eh,
auch einfach in PDF Viewer Unterschrift prüfen könnten, eine digitale. So, also das Einzige, was an dem Ding technisch sinnvoll ist
ist ähm dass man die Zeugnisdaten maschienen lesbar irgendwie mit einem XML da drinnen speichert.
Aber das müsste man sich auch gleich wieder die gesellschaftliche Frage stellen, ob wir das überhaupt wollen, dass man irgendwelche Zeugnisdaten so komplett vollautomatisiert auslesen kann. Ich hatte ein sehr gutes Abitur, aber äh,
finde, dass das eigentlich kein sinnvoller Bewertungsmaßstab ist. Bei irgendwelchen Bewerbungsverfahren oder so was.
Also du du würdest natürlich die du könntest dadurch
äh den Prozess beschleunigen
Das wären.
Und und es ist ja also von derartigen Bestrebungen, von den Unternehmen hören wir ja immer wieder und vor allem auch, wie sie schief gehen, ne. Besser also versucht den den Bewerbungs- und Auswahlprozess irgendwie
zu automatisieren, ähm,
um am Ende irgendwie diesen Prozess der Bewerberinnenauswahl und.
Also jetzt müssen wir vielleicht auch sagen, dass wir beide ja den im Prinzip den gleichen Job machen, also IT-Security, in diesem Bereich ist, sage ich mal, sind formale Qualifikationen, nicht nicht nennenswert aussagekräftig.
Ja? Ähm,
oder man würde zumindest nicht auf die Idee kommen, Leute nach Schulnoten zu sortieren und wenn dann auf jeden Fall andersrum. Ja und ähm das.
Scheiße, scheiße jetzt äh darf ich niemandem sagen, was ich für ein Abiturzeug.
Ne, aber also jetzt ich wir müssen vielleicht da mal sagen, dass wir.
Nicht genau wissen, wie das in anderen,
weiß nicht, wie das heute ist bei der Studienplatzvergabe er halt selbstverständlich der in Szenerolle gespielt,
und ähm.
Da eine Maschinen äh äh ähm
also eine maschinenlesbare Erfassung und automatische Auswahl durchzuführen. Erleichtert auf jeden Fall Prozesse
Leuten, die diese Kriterien nicht treffen,
schneller an eine unsichtbare Wand geraten, dass sie niemals von einem Menschen wahrgenommen werden, ne. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, das ist
eigentlich ohnehin so, weil ich glaube, als würde ich mich damals bei der ZVS eintragen musste, musste ich natürlich auch den NC nochmal irgendwo eintippen, den ich hatte und ähm
hätte ich da einen falschen eingegeben, hätte man das irgendwie gemerkt, ja, aber wenn man diese Prozesse halt standardisiert und digitalisiert, dann werden sie halt auch von allen irgendwie gemacht, ne? Und dann wird das halt, was weiß ich, demnächst
bei was weiß ich, bei Xing oder LinkedIn oder bei Preezy oder wie sie alle heißen, einfach.
Eingebaut und das ist glaube ich so der das was was du meinst mit dem der gesellschaftlichen.
Ja also ich meine
du siehst, man kann über dieses Thema und wie man damit irgendwie als Gesellschaft so mit Schulnoten und so weiter umgehen möchte. Hervorragend äh diskutieren. Aber stattdessen ist es da so, dass da irgendwie eine Million in so ein Quatsch-Projekt reinversenkt wird, ohne dass es da irgendeine Diskussion gibt und wenn man
irgendwie probiert schon im Vorfeld irgendwie auf die Leute zuzugehen und zu sagen sag mal
was ihr da macht ist irgendwie Quatsch und das kann man technisch so und so irgendwie günstiger, einfacher, schneller lösen, dann dann hören die einem nicht zu und wenn man's dann hinterher kaputt.
Nervt mich total. Also man muss es kaputt spielen, dann bekommt man da irgendwie total viel Aufmerksamkeit auf diese Sache drauf und,
dann ähm dann dann hat es äh dann gucken muss ich jetzt die Leute an und dann heißt es wieder so ja immer diese blöden Hacker, die immer irgendwas kaputt machen tun oder alternativ heißt es immer dieser,
Datenschutz äh that's why we can't have nice things so, aber mal irgendwie im Vorfeld zuzuhören. Ich meine, wir sind ja grad auch noch in anderen Sache dran. So, probiert man mal irgendwie auf.
Politiker irgendwie zuzugehen ihnen zu sagen, hey guck mal hier, ihr habt da ein Problem,
Nicht viel so. Ja, finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen frustrierend.
Zumal jetzt also ich denke, es ist auch, das ist ja genau der Punkt, ne? Also das was was ihr jetzt da gefunden habt, also,
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe ähm.
XSS okay das ist eine das wird sich im Zweifelsfall.
Ausbauen lassen zu es gibt wird eine grüne Seite angezeigt, wenn man das PDF hochlädt, wäre das möglich gewesen.
Mhm. Ja auf jeden Fall. Also das würde mit einer XSS gehen
und äh da haben wir auch schon genau das Problem so. Du musst halt, wenn du so eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hast, musst du erklären, wie wie funktioniert die so. Dass bei einer XSS kriegt man das noch irgendwie sinnvoll verargumentiert. So das kann man verständlich äh
bereiten. Aber wenn wir uns dann irgendwie komplexere Themen anschauen dann wird es irgendwann schwierig und es ist natürlich dann auch schwierig äh für irgendwelche Leute die sich nicht mit Technik befassen äh.
Zu beurteilen. Ähm.
Den tatsächlichen Impact
zu zu bewerten so. Ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, dass so eine XS jetzt nicht so riesengroß dramatisch ist. Es ist halt einfach nur Hochnot peinlich für eine eine äh Bundesdruckerei. Ja, absolut.
Also vielleicht zur Übersetzung kurz äh XSS, also Crossside Skripting haben wir auch schon so erwähnt. Das heißt das quasi und das ist einfach so eine Attacke, die einfach eine Schwäche im Browser über Javascript äh ausnutzt so und die.
Die Schwäche
äh nicht nur im Browser, sondern äh die Schwäche ist, dass der Server von einem Bundesdruckerei, quatsch, den ich rein äh stecke, zurück reflektiert und der Browser dann Code, den ich da reinschreiben kann, äh ausführt.
Also beispielsweise meine Note in Physik ist,
spitze Klammer auf, Java Skript und dann schreibst du da deinen Code hin und mit diesem Java-Script könnte kannst ja dann quasi den die komplette Seite anders aussehen lassen, ja? Läste dann halt sagst du die Note in Sport ist Java Script
überall eine 1 und unten einen grünen Balken hinmalen, ja? Und das so,
vereinfacht würde ich mir jetzt so eine XSS äh vorstellen und weil du das irgendwie da rein kriegst, äh weil du's irgendwie dahingeschickt kriegst und der Server das ungeprüft zurückgibt und nicht sieht, dass das gerade Javascript ist, was jetzt der
was der Browser dann wieder rendern und ausführen wird.
Den gesamten Kontext, in dem du dargestellt wirst, nach Belieben zu verändern, wie es ein Java-Script, was der,
Programmierer dort mal haben wollte oder was der was der Service dort mal haben wollte, was dort mal,
gewillt äh äh gezielt hingesetzt wurde, äh ausgeführt wird. Habe ich das richtig zusammengefasst, Luke.
Und die äh Beispielattacke, die ich davor geführt hatte, äh war einfach äh hier ist mein Abiturzeugnis äh eins Komma eins äh
doch mal und dann wurde man weitergeleitet. Ähm also ich habe da Code reingeschrieben. Der ist eine kurze Textnachricht äh darstellt in so einer Alertbox und dann wurde man weitergeleitet äh zum äh Rick Roll.
So very easy und da könnte man natürlich dann auch, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, irgendwie äh ein Abiturzeugnis reinpinseln, was dann irgendwie eine eins Komma eins also das äh NC hat.
Man muss dazu sagen, XS ist ein häufiges Problem. Das ist äh äh,
eigentlich äh ja äh gehört halt zu den zu den ersten Sachen, die in so einem Pantest halt irgendwie auftauchen. Insofern ist das primär peinlich äh weniger ähm also ich würde so eine Hygienesache, oder?
Also es sieht hier es ist jetzt nicht etwas, was häufig ausgenutzt wird.
Zum zum Leidwesen anderer, aber es eignet sich sehr dazu, das zu machen für gezielte Angriffe und wenn du wenn du halt sagst, ey wir sind hier eine Webseite, wo die Zeugnisse verifiziert, was sowieso eine sehr dumme Idee ist. Dann sollte
die zumindest nicht äh den Code ausführen, der im Zeugnis steht, so ungefähr.
Also es ist äh
by the way nicht zeugt was äh äh das ist nicht Zeug was im Zeugnis steht, sondern man konnte über so einen API Punkt Informationen zu einer bestimmten Organisation abrufen und wenn es die Organisation nicht gibt, die sei die, dann wurde die zurück reflektiert und,
einen Code reinschreiben und äh noch eine ganz interessante äh Randnotiz ist, dass sie
Basic Clean nur wegen dem paar Sachen, die Lilit und ich da jetzt aufgelistet haben. Die ganze Kiste mehr oder weniger in Santan offline genommen haben, was halt auch noch mal peinlich ist. Das ist halt so ein so ein die Probleme, die wir da aufgezeigt haben, sind halt Sachen, die die patched man eben.
Geht die Kiste wieder online so. Da sich komplett äh da komplett den Stecker zu ziehen ist halt auch nochmal on top irgendwie peinlich, finde ich.
Ich find's vor allem peinlich, dass man also dass man sich nicht schämt für die Idee. Ja, also du hast es ja vorhin auch schon gesagt. Was soll denn das bitte? Alle Zeugnisse in so einer öffentlichen Datenbank vorzuhalten.
Es geht nicht darum, da tatsächlich die Zeugnisse an sich fortzuhalten. Also da können wir auch noch mal, kann ich auch noch mal ein bisschen ausholen. Äh man kann die Zeugnisse wohl auch darüber abrufen. Es gab so einen so einen Download-Formular und dann steckt
man da irgendwie einen Abrufcode und ein Passwort rein. Da habe ich nur gesehen, dass diese beiden Werte dann an irgendeinen Backend gepostet,
das heißt ich stelle mir das so vor, dass der Service dann da in der Lage äh oder zumindest ja in der Lage ist, das Zeugnis zu entschlüsseln und
die alle da irgendwie vorliegen. Das ist aber nur Mutmaßung. Äh tatsächlich in der Blockchain sollten nur irgendwelche Hashes gespeichert werden, also da sollten dann keine äh personenbezogenen Daten von diesen Zeugnissen drinne landen. Insofern hat man da schon irgendwie äh verstanden, dass Datenschutz irgendwie wichtig ist.
Aber halt auf eine komplett falsche Art und Weise falsch verstanden. Man bräuchte diese Hashes gar nicht erspeichern, sondern kann halt einfach offline eine Signatur unter das Ding drunter klatschen und fertig ist. Da braucht man keine Systeme, keine Cyberfape betreiben. Muss man keine
kein kein Strom für verschwinden und Steuergelder. Es ist einfach alles.
Also man um das Ziel zu erreichen ist es überhaupt nicht erforderlich irgendwelche Server zu betreiben,
sondern man kann halt einfach sich die Datei signieren lassen, dann hat man die insigniert und wenn man die jetzt irgendwo vorlegt, dann gibt
man da die Datei hin, lädt sie irgendwo hoch oder schickt sie äh per Mail und dann kann die Person der Datei
dass selbst Ansehen, dass die stimmt so und sollte die Software an der Stelle äh äh mit dieser Zertifizierungsinfrastruktur nichts ähm anfangen können. Gibt's genug Programme, die das dann einfach mal machen können?
Die ganze Idee das halt überhaupt so Server und Webbasiert irgendwie zu präsentieren ist schon meiner Aufassung nach vollkommen überflüssig und dann muss dann auch noch mal dieser Blockchainnebel äh dann noch durchwehen,
der der irgendwie insofern verstörend ist, als das natürlich,
damit assoziiert. Nur dass das was die Kryptogelder da machen an Blockchain hier überhaupt nicht erforderlich ist,
Es ist nichts wo die ganze Welt auf einmal mit rechnet und irgendwie sich gegenseitig vertrauen müssen, sondern es gibt hier eine zentrale Vertrauensinstanz und diese ganze Blockchain ist einfach vollkommen,
überflüssig und keiner braucht das und und das ist diese Idiotie, die man irgendwie nicht.
Das ist.
Sind einfach nichts.
Aber das ist, weißt du, was ich glaube, was da also du erinnerst dich ja.
Sie sagten Impfzertifikat in der Blockchain, ne und dann wurde einfach irgendwann gesagt so, hört auf mit dem Scheiß, lasst es und dann haben sie gesagt, na okay, lassen wir den Blockchain weg. Die im Prinzip haben sie sich ja gedacht, okay super äh,
weniger Geld, ja? Äh also wir müssen weniger Geld ausgeben fürs Gleiche. Wahrscheinlich berechnen wir jetzt noch mal extra, dass wir die Blockchain wieder rausschneiden. Aber am Ende mussten die ja nicht viel ändern. Das Ding hat ja genauso funktioniert, ohne die Blockchain dran.
Und mein Eindruck ist aber, dass sie gerade halt, also dass das das Spielchen, was gerade gespielt wird eigentlich ist zu sagen hm,
Wir werden ja bescheuert was mit der Blockchain zu machen, weil die Idee einer Blockchain ist ja, sie ist verteilt und kann durch alle verifiziert werden,
Wir wollen ja, wir wollen ja ein Geschäftsmodell haben. Wir wollen ja als Bundesdruckerei für den für den Rest der Zeit, die es noch Schulen und Zeugnisse gibt.
Irgendwie Geld dafür verdienen, dass wir diesen Verifikationsdienst herstellen. Wir machen doch nicht wir machen doch nicht ausm lebenslangen ähm,
Businessmodell, eine Blockchain die am Ende irgendwie wo wir uns selber überflüssig machen. Und das ist glaube ich genau der Grund warum du diese,
Unsinnsprojekte hast, wo sie sagen, ja ja, wir machen det eine Blockchain, keine Sorge und eine Webseite, wo ihr zentral von uns abhängig seid,
weil keiner verstanden hat, warum es Blockchains,
und warum nicht? Oder also wofür man sie braucht und warum nicht sagen alle super da haben wir hier ein Budget für, da sind wir innovativ, da fragen wir nochmal den Andreas Scheuer, der hat da auch Ahnung von so und,
weißt du und dann läuft der Hase so und ich glaube, also ich ich glaube auch wirklich ernsthaft.
Irgendwo, ja, ich glaube an die Verschwörung, dass irgendwo in dieser ganzen Kette Leute sitzen,
ist die Blockchain, die ich brauche einfach nur da dran stehen muss und die einfach, sage ich mal, geistig weiter sind als wir zu sagen, ja, ja, Blockchain,
So und das ist einfach Hauptsache der Rubel rollt und Hauptsache die anderen kaufen die Scheiße und wenn das nicht mehr Blockchain heißen soll, sondern was weiß ich wie wie die nächste Sau heißt hier durchs Dorf getrieben wird. Dann schreiben wir das eben da dran.
Ja und äh äh ich also ich anders kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie ein solcher Quatsch überhaupt ähm.
Das ist einfach, ich ich erinnere mich noch, ich bin irgendwie mal vor vor 20 Jahren mich irgendwie mal so mit dem Vorstand von Beate Uhse irgendwie äh im Flugzeug gesessen und sind irgendwie durch die Gegend ge.
Wie heißen wir im Vorstand von Beate Uhse? Beate Uhse oder nicht?
Mehrere Leute so. Ich,
keine Namen nennen, aber es war auf jeden Fall so und dann dachte ich mir so nutze ich mal die Gelegenheit und frage mal so so ein bisschen was sind hier irgendwie mit diesen ganzen Peniserektions äh äh Wässerchen ist und so weiter so und die
auch nur so ein bisschen amüsiert äh an die Decke und meinten so na ja also wer's glaubt irgendwie so.
Und ich glaube so ein bisschen ist es halt mit dieser Blockchain dann irgendwie in dieser IT-Branche halt auch so ein bisschen wie so mit so äh Peniserektions äh äh Hilf Gedöns so äh die du halt so einen Pornoshop kaufen kannst.
Wenn du dran glaubst, dass deine Projekte geiler sind, wenn da Blockchain draufsteht und du dafür extra bezahlst, wir nehmen dir die Kohle gerne ab.
Okay.
Weil also selbstverständlich jeder, der sich technisch damit beschäftigt und halbwegs beschlagen ist und und irgendwie da reinschaut, versteht das, sondern das nicht braucht,
ja? Die sagen bloß nee das musste aber draufstehen,
Weil dann klingt es neu und geil und außerdem hat die Bundesregierung da gesagt, das ist jetzt die Zukunft und das steht in unserem Regierungsprogramm und da steht ja auch irgendwie in der aktuellen Koalitionsvertrag und deswegen müssen wir das jetzt einfach machen, weil das ist jetzt einfach der heiße Scheiß.
Müssen das einfach machen, weil alle anderen reden ja auch darüber. Wenn du das nicht machst, dann bist du ja nicht mehr hip.
So funktioniert das einfach und äh technisch gibt's einfach keinen,
Grund und wir werden jetzt noch mehr über diesen ganzen Blockchain-Unsinn reden. Das zieht sich einfach über diese ganze Nummer komplett
durch und und dieser Irrsinns-Glaube äh es würde sich hier in irgendeiner Form um eine Zukunftstechnologie handeln,
ist einfach schwer wieder aus den Hirn rauszuprügeln. Wird natürlich kommen, aber dauert.
Aber das ist ja das ist ja das, was Flipke gerade auch meinte, ne, dass du sagst, äh okay, du sagst hin
Bevor sie damit anfangen, dass es Quatsch. Während sie's machen, das ist Quatsch. Wenn sie fertig sind, das ist Quatsch. Aber wenn du eine XSS drin findest, dann kriegst du auf einmal Aufmerksamkeit, ne.
Ja, das ist.
Und dann geht die ganze Kiste von jetzt auf gleich offline.
Ich meine, Blockchain ist doch auch eine total super Ausrede irgendwie mit der Digitalisierung nicht fertig zu werden. Soll es doch guck mal, das ist eine neue Technologie. Das muss man erst mal erforschen und da muss man ganz viel Geld reinstecken. Da gibt's ja noch nichts Fertiges und so.
Wir können ja hier nicht einfach so eine fertige Lösung aus dem Regal nehmen, sondern müssen erstmal das nochmal selber bauen mit Blockchain und da ganz viel Geld versenken.
Die ist für uns alle Neuland.
Ja das ist es ist doch der totale Irrwirrwitz. Ich meine wie viele komische äh äh Dörfer es gibt, die sich irgendwie so als Blockchain-Standort irgendwie äh geben.
Du gerade was gegen Mittweider gesagt?
So hieß der Ort, ne? Oh Gott. Wo ist das in Sachsen?
Die die haben auf jeden Fall einen äh Blockchain-Studium an ihrer Universität da in Sachsen?
Ist das geil.
Twitter sollte mal auf Blockchain setzen, die sind grad offline. Ist das.
Twitter setzt gerade auf Blockchain.
Und sollten auf Blockchain setzen, dann würden sie nicht offline gehen.
Ja klar.
Haben wir ja bei den Zeugnissen gesehen, wie gut die wie die wie gut die nicht offline gegangen.
Ja ne, wenn die wenn die wenn die eine Instanz offline geht, ne genau, das ist ja dieses Web drei, das geht ja nicht offline, ne.
Vor allem kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass wenn dir gar keiner ein Interesse da, ach lass mir das, okay.
Es wird nach Amüsanter. Na gut, also soviel zu dem Blockchain äh äh Zeugnissen. Ihr habt da ein bisschen dran rumgebrockelt. Alle haben sich aufgeregt, aber am Ende ist noch keiner bereit zuzugeben, dass es alles Unsinn ist und es wird jetzt einfach noch eine Weile dauern.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Oder es lebt so so halb tot weiter, wie wir es ja von anderen Blockchain-Projekten auch kennen.
Das ist natürlich, ich meine, bei der bei der Bundesdruckerei sind wir natürlich bei äh solchen Leuten.
Genauso wie das HPI, das ist so ein so ein so ein schönes Konglomerat HPI Bundesdruckerei und ne.
Das ist so eine Zusammenrottung, habe ich eher den Eindruck, ne?
Ja, aber im Gegensatz zu der anderen Zusammenrottung haben die nicht eine Abneigung zu dem Innovationsbereich Blockchain.
Äh und äh äh die dann äh,
Also warum glaube ich gerade dieser ganze Blockchain-Kram auch insbesondere in der Nähe zum äh Start halt so gut geritten werden kann?
Ist, weil die sich immer denken, ey Scheiße Günther, bei der dot com Blase waren wir irgendwie ein,
gut, ne? Dann kam Web zwei null, da haben wir auch irgendwie nicht mitgemacht. Und jetzt jetzt kommt irgendwie Web drei, NFT Blockchain. Jetzt müssen wir endlich mal, jetzt machen wir,
ne? Die Unabhängigkeit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist zum Greifen nah. Wir werden äh Weltmarktführer in der Blockchain und,
natürlich sitzen da irgendwelche Politiker und sagen, kommt Leute,
ich habe jetzt fünfmal kamt ihr mit mit diesem Internet und digital.
Wir können's irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass das was ist, ja und ausgerechnet jetzt, wo sie mit so einem Zonk ankommen, finden sie überall Gehör, weil alle sagen so, okay, ne komm, wir haben jetzt oft genug nicht mitgemacht,
Jetzt kippen wir, jetzt kippen wir aber alles rein, ja? Diesmal reiten wir die Welle aber ganz, ganz vorne mit.
Und das das das ist so so schmerzhaft zu sehen, wo du halt denkst, so das habt ihr bei jedes Mal, als da eine sinnvolle Technologie,
vorgestellt wurde, die euch erklärt werden konnte, wo man auch wo man sage ich mal ein Potential der Idee sehen konnte und so weiter. Zum Beispiel wir vernetzen dieses Land mit,
Internet. Da habt ihr gesagt, nee können wir das ist ja wohl Kappes, ja. Aber wenn du sagst, hier Blockchain-Zeugnis, dann sagen alle so
Juhai, die Kinder werden alle klug, weil sie in der Blockchain sind und wir machen jetzt Exzellenzcluster Blockchain in irgendeinem Dorf und dann wird das äh dann geht das richtig ab hier.
Das ist schon sehr bedauerlich.
Für dich. Aber okay, ich bin ja auch ein Idealist.
Das ist auch so ein Projekt, das so halt,
weiterlebt.
Wissen wir auch nicht so richtig. Also die haben noch keine Entscheidung getroffen, so wie's damit jetzt weitergehen soll. Reden aber schon mal mit dem BSI, äh wie sie das irgendwie sicherer machen wollen und was sie da irgendwie dran ändern wollen. Äh kann ich auch gerne mal noch verlinken hier in die Shownotes, äh die die Antwort. Ähm das sind
Thema, was äh die das Team da äh die ganze Zeit schon mitverfolgt, was ich total super finde. Darüber haben wir einige Sachen herausgefunden, über diese Anfragen. Ähm,
Genau und ähm das Projekt ist also offensichtlich nicht,
ich hätte eigentlich jetzt erwartet, dass mit der neuen Bundesregierung ähm da eine klare Absage an dieses gescheiterte Projekt der Vorgängerregierung äh erteilt wird.
Weil ähm man macht sich ja ich meine das kann man ja alles auf die Vorgängerregierung schieben so und da muss man sich ja nicht die Hände dran schmutzig machen so. Ähm
Na jedenfalls geht es weiter und es gibt auch äh nach wie vor irgendwie sehr viel Lobbyarbeit äh so aus dem Bankenumfeld, die wirklich diese Lösung unbedingt haben wollen und
da frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt so, warum wollen die das eigentlich? Also als Bank irgendwie gut
Banken reiten gerne tote Pferde so. Das ist jetzt ja irgendwie nichts Neues. Aber wieso will ich als Bank so ein so ein so eine Block
Identifizierungslösung, wo ich im Zweifelsfall äh hinterher nicht sicher weiß, wer eigentlich mein Kunde ist. Eigentlich sollten doch Banken so geldwäschegesetzmäßig in so ein Interesse dran haben, ein möglichst sicheres System einzusetzen.
Da würde ich wahrscheinlich vorsichtig widersprechen, weil was die eigentlich,
verhältnismäßig egal jetzt also der Identifikation ihrer Kunden ne also äh ähm die müssen natürlich den dem Geldwäschegesetz entsprechend äh Authentifizierungen oder ja Authentifizierung durchführen, irgendwie sicherstellen.
Fun Fact äh das ist eine Sache, wo sie dran sägen da an dem Geldwäschegesetz. Sie wollen haben da so eine Experimentierklause, die einen äh sehr wichtig ist.
Richtig und ich glaube nämlich, die wollen einfach so also sie sagen einfach, okay pass auf, hm hier macht jemand ein Konto auf, dann müssen wir
äh wir wir erkennen die Abbruchquote in dem Moment wo wir sagen, machen wir jetzt hier äh Post-Ident oder Foto-Ident oder sonst was, die ist uns zu hoch, ja. Ähm
Das heißt, äh ne, dieser Prozess im,
auf dem Weg zum Depot oder zur Kontoeröffnung oder sonst was,
möchten wir, dass das einfacher geht und äh,
Ob das nachher sicherer ist oder nicht, ist uns ja völlig egal, weil,
in Ordnung sein. Ja, also es geht ja nicht unbedingt also die Banken haben ja kein Interesse, jetzt eine sichere Authentifizierung zu machen. Die haben eine ein Interesse daran, eine äh rechtssichere Authentifizierung zu machen. Und wenn die einfacher geht.
Zu Lasten der Sicherheit, aber diese einfachere anfälligere Authentifizierung ist äh von ihrer Seite so, dass sie nicht mehr das Risiko tragen,
äh dann ist ihnen das ja nur recht und billig, oder? Also dass sie halt sagen, okay, Authentifizierung.
Meine Sache wo wo man mal äh nachhaken müsste so wer haftet eigentlich bei diesem SSI wenn da jetzt irgendwie Geldwäsche drüber betrieben wird oder falsche Konten eröffnet werden?
Du die Banken, die Banken haften nur, wenn sie da äh Hinweise nicht nachgehen, ne. Also das kannst du dir ja diese die derartige Verfahren kannst du dir anschauen. And twenty-six hatte dann irgendwann mal Probleme, ne, weil sie,
Hinweisen nicht.
Da hatte ich auch neulich einen Scammer tatsächlich, der wollte, dass ich äh ihm auf eBay Kleinanzeigen Geld auf ein Konto überweisen und die ganzen Umstände waren in dieser Sketchi so.
Ganz normaler, ganz normaler äh Junior beim Start-up, aber okay.
Äh nee, waren noch andere Sachen, die da äh Sketchy waren. Aber äh zu der Abbruchquote, ne, dann dann sollen sie halt einfach diese Ausweis-App zwei Gutscheine nach dir hat. Sehr schlechtes Marketing-Ausweis-App,
zwei, what the fuck, so warum nicht Ausweis-App drei oder vier. Äh jedenfalls.
Ich die erste hat glaube ich auch keiner mitbekommen um ehrlich zu sein.
Erste Version drei elf kann wirklich benutzt.
Workgroups, ja?
Jedenfalls ich habe die Tage mal bei so einem Kreditunternehmen äh ein Konto aufgemacht und da dachte ich mir, ach so, jetzt muss ich mich wieder vor irgendwo vor die Kamera setzen und irgendwie meinen Perso zeigen und,
Person auf dem Perso sieht irgendwie wenig aus wie ich und dann macht das wieder Probleme, sondern da ging das recht easy. Ich habe halt einfach meine Ausweis-App rausgeholt, da habe ich meinen Personalausweis äh rausgeholt, den ans Telefon gehalten und fertig. Nach einer halben Minute war ich durch.
Ein gelöstes Problem so braucht er ist halt nur nicht so fancy und shiny und
dann dann müsste man halt irgendwie so ein so ein UX-Team irgendwie rübergehen, so was was diese Ausweis-App angeht.
Und einen Rapper.
Zumal diese Funktionalität auch in absehbarer Zeit ohnehin von den Smartphonebetriebssystemen äh eingeführt werden wird. Also bei iOS geht das jetzt schon los in USA. Also es gibt
die technischen Standards um so ein äh US-Führerschein ins Telefon reinzubekommen, damit der sich entsprechend digital melden kann und das wird
über kurz oder lang der Standard.
Da bist du jetzt ein bisschen da kriegst du jetzt wieder Apple äh aufm.
Mit dieses Apple nix zu tun. Es gibt einfach die Standards, die im.
Diese NFC-Standards und die äh die Secure äh Module Standards die waren tatsächlich als allererstes auf Android geraten, ja. Also das da da waren wir,
noch letztes Jahr in dieser Anhörung zum äh.
Auch nicht gesagt, dass es von Apple ja es es ist, es kommt jetzt in den in den Betriebssystem, es kommt doch genauso bei Google äh und und das ist der einzige Weg, über den so was überhaupt funktionieren kann. Aber so irgendwelche Herunterladbaren, schlecht benannten,
schlecht zu benutzenden Apps, die komplett auseinanderfallen, wenn man sie mal schräg anguckt.
Einfach nicht der Weg. Also da wird auch einfach nicht da wird einfach nicht weit genug gedacht. Selbstverständlich braucht man für,
nichts anderes als ein weltweit gesprochenen Standard. Da muss man sich auf höchster Ebene drum bemühen, das zu standardisieren und da muss man irgendwie mit allen Playern.
Die SSI-Eil-Leute ja tatsächlich. Die probieren hier gerade äh das auf europäischer Ebene durchzudrücken
und man versucht irgendwie sich jetzt auch die Impfpässe mit äh
dazuzunehmen, so als Anwendungsfall, um dann nur hohe Installationsbasis äh zu garantieren. Aber um noch mal ganz kurz auf die Frage zurückzukommen, wie's jetzt mit der ID-Wallet eigentlich weitergeht.
Das ist jetzt zumindest die Antwort der Bundesregierung gewesen, so wissen wir nicht und aber wir wir reden hier noch und das Projekt also
TilDR der Antwort von der Bundesregierung, dass das Projekt ist nicht tot und ähm aus äh den äh.
Aus dem Konsort zum äh heißt es, äh dass es da am 22.4. einen neuen Release geben wird,
dann wenden sich Lilit und ich das auf jeden Fall wieder anschauen, was sie da gebaut haben, aber
Es wird natürlich mit jeder Iteration schwieriger da irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken drin zu finden. Dann sind wir wieder beim Thema so, dass es halt
per se eine schlechte Idee ist und dass es halt einfach schon eine Lösung gibt, die man halt einfach nur besser machen muss und irgendwie zugänglicher gestalten sollte. So aber insgesamt äh finde ich brauchen wir nicht so ein äh so eine App-Lösung für das Ganze, sondern brauchen eine,
Erstmal eine sicherere Lösung, die irgendwie mit einem Securelement oder sowas äh funktioniert
glaube die Apple-Lösung, da ist auch mit einem äh Secure-Element Android der Platform Security von diesem 0815 Android würde ich so gar nicht über den Weg trauen und äh zum anderen ähm
ja weiß nicht, so so ein Personalausweis vorzeigen, finde ich. Das muss ein manueller Akt bleiben. Also ich ich finde das richtig,
man irgendwie für diese
zeige jetzt meinen Personalausweis vor. Das ist nicht normal. Das mache ich nicht alle Tage so. Das mache ich vielleicht in einer wenn wenn die Bullen mich kontrollieren oder so.
Da ärgere ich mich auch jedes Mal, ne, wenn die Bullen mich kontrollieren, dass ich das ist doch oh Mann ey, jetzt nimmst du so eine Karte aus der Tasche holen, da kann ich nicht einfach mit einer App,
jetzt hier also es ist ja auch so, welches Problem wollen Sie lösen.
Na mein Punkt ist, wenn's halt irgendwie so ein System gibt, was äh einfacher funktioniert aus Nutzerinnen Perspektive, dann wird das halt
bei jedem Scheiß integriert und dann werden halt irgendwelche Prozesse, die vorher irgendwie auch anonym oder pseudonym ging, plötzlich ähm mit mit
staatlichen Identitäten versehen, obwohl das überhaupt nicht notwendig wäre so.
Das ist das ist genau also das ist genau der Punkt, dass man jetzt eben sagt, komm wir machen,
ausweisen einfacher. Ja und ich glaube, also ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Interesse,
Ich glaube wirklich, dass die Banken da einfach ein Interesse haben, weil die müssen die ganze Zeit Leute ausweisen und die wenn man das denen einfacher macht, dann ne, ist es für die irgendwie eben einfacher.
Aber die Konsequenz ist eben auch,
Die gesellschaftliche Änderung, die ähm,
die jetzt noch keiner so wirklich oder an die, die Leute dabei grade nicht denken. Nur diejenigen, die sich halt, ne, darüber mal Gedanken machen.
Wir haben jetzt ja auch äh mit den Impfpässen die Situation erreicht, dass wir uns äh überall und nirgendwo ähm ausweisen müssen. So das wird sehr wahrscheinlich wieder verschwinden, wenn die Pandemie vorbei ist, was wir alle hoffen. Ähm und ähm,
Genau, aber in dem Zusammenhang sehe ich gerade noch,
Die Gefahr, dass wir mit diesem äh Ticketing-System, was jetzt in die CWA da reingehackt äh wurde von T-Systems, äh ein System bekommen, wo wir uns auch irgendwie dann regelmäßig äh identifizieren müssen, zum Beispiel um,
Konzerttickets oder sowas zu kaufen, was früher irgendwie auch noch anonym oder pseudonym ging.
Absolut. Ne das also diese diese derartige Prozesse vielleicht ein bisschen komplizierter zu gestalten,
hat auch seine Vorteile, ja. Stattdessen also na ja Luca App ja wirklich ein ein unschönes Thema, aber dieser die haben wir jetzt glaube ich dann auch gesagt. Ja der Ausweis der kommt jetzt auch noch da rein. Und äh was nicht alles? Also.
Kann ich mir damit schon Essen bestellen?
Die machen da jetzt rein, was was geht, aber äh also ich denke,
finde es sehr wichtig, dass du sagst so diesen Prozess des Ausweisens äh ne ich nehme das Ding jetzt, ich halte es an mein Handy dass das eigentlich wirklich eine eine ähm.
Eine elegante Lösung ist, die auch die Bedeutung ähm.
Hier ja auch.
Alle paar Jahre oder doch alle paar Jahre kommt ein Innenminister daher und sagt Personalausweispflicht im Internet. Ja oder dann und,
und jedes Mal wird gesagt, hör mal.
Ihren Vogel, ja, aber wenn diese Technologien natürlich dahin kommen, dass dass,
zu erledigen ist oder sogar eingebaut ist, dass dein Handy eben dein Personalausweis ist und dann einfach mal den mitsendet. Nur falls den jemand haben will
dann brauchst du dich gar nicht mehr ausweisen. Du bist ja schon ausgewiesen, ne? Dann hast du das hast du diese hast du
die Technologie nicht mit einem mit einem Push reingebracht, sondern mit einem Pult, weil alle sagen geil, ich will mich mitm Handy ausweisen, ja? Also es ist eigentlich eine eine völlig irrsinnige Idee, weil weil Identifizierung mit Ausweis in der Regel etwas ist, was nicht
unbedingt für einen also was ist nicht unbedingt mit meinem Interesse, mich auszuweisen? In der Regel mache ich das in Situationen, wo das Ausweisen.
In letzter Instanz etwas ist, was gegen mich gemacht wird, nicht für mich.
Mitm Telefon ausweisen. Das erinnert mich an die Sicherheitslücke, die ich mir bei der Telekom gefunden hatte. Und zwar konnte man mit nur so äh,
zwei äh HTTP Requests vom Telefon ausgehend die eigene Rufnummer rausfinden und eine Rufnummer ist ja quasi so in Deutschland und ganz Europa mittlerweile war's so was wie eine Identität.
Aber das nur nebenbei. Haben sie sehr schnell gefixt und unter 24 Stunden. Also ich finde, man muss ja auch mal irgendwie positive Beispiele erwähnen, die ich denen zukommen lassen, ham sie äh sofort professionell reagiert und gefixt.
Und der der andere Fähre gewesen, den den Request mit einzubauen, dass man.
Eine Ausnutzung äh wäre gewesen, dass man äh die Benutzer in identifizieren kann, wenn sie äh wiederkommen. Ich meine, da gibt's natürlich auch diverse andere Möglichkeit,
Cookies, Google Analytics und weiß der Geier was. Aber so eine Telefonnummer zu haben ist natürlich schon ganz praktisch. Vor allem wenn man bedenkt, dass das äh diverse Sheidi Drittanbieter Services so ein Premium-Services gibt, die man irgendwie mit seiner Mobilfunknummer. Ich kenne mich da in,
ganzen nicht so weiter aus, aber ähm,
Ich hatte meine italienische Rufnummer und äh die ist irgendwo mal geliebt und dann haben da Leute, ach egal, wat der war. Ähm,
auf jeden Fall nicht schön gewesen, aber wurde auf jeden Fall sehr professionell gefixt und schnell reagiert und äh ja.
Tim.
Ich.
Ja weder noch, ne? Also bezahlen kann man damit ja gar nix und äh wenn man damit wirklich was bezahlen wollen würde, dann äh wäre man eigentlich schön blöd, ne.
NFT kann man mit I verkaufen.
Ja du mich auch. Also.
Wo fängt man da an? Also was glaube ich einfach mal langsam mal klar,
werden muss in dieser ganzen Blockchain-Debatte ist halt einfach.
Was ist das eigentlich? Was passiert da eigentlich gerade, wovon reden eigentlich gerade alle? Und es gibt da einfach.
So eine richtig beunruhigende Welle, die durch dieses Internet zieht,
und immer mehr Leute glauben offenbar, dass das was Tolles ist. Es es hat also wirklich auch in Teilen,
auch schon so Querdenker äh äh Züge, mindestens aber so ein Religionscharakter und diese Religion heißt wir werden alle reich.
Nix Neues so, wir hatten irgendwie die nigerianischen Prinzen, die haben uns das irgendwie per E-Mail auch alle schon die ganze Zeit erzählt.
Am Ende war's halt immer irgendwie ein Scam und man kann sich das vielleicht auch mal generell einfach mal kurz notieren. Nicht nur fürs Internet, sondern auch so fürs fürs echte Leben,
Wenn so Leute zu dir kommen und sagen hey ich kann dir sagen wie du reich wirst.
Sonst.
Wenn die Leute wüssten,
Es gibt halt tausend Dinge, die immer wieder probiert werden und es gibt eben auch so tausend Dinge, die immer wieder funktionieren,
und äh die haben auch schöne Namen, ja, äh kehren dann in gewisser Hinsicht immer wieder. Ja, das ist vor allem dieses
bekannte Ponzies geben, wo der Herr Ponsi halt irgendwie die ganze Zeit auch nur heiße Luft äh verkauft hat und permanent davon profitiert hat, aber so ganz allgemein gibt's halt einfach immer wieder diese Pyramidensysteme
bin da auch als junger Kerl auch mal drauf reingefallen.
Bitcoin haben sie sich mit Bitcoin verarscht.
Damals gab's gab's das noch nicht so. Nee nee das waren das waren so,
weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich da überhaupt dran geraten bin, ne und ich war einfach noch jung und dumm,
und habe mir dann halt irgendwie auch da einen einreden lassen, ja hier voll das geile System,
gibt dann irgendwie tausend Euro weiter oder 1hundert Euro, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das äh Euro sowieso nicht mag damals irgendwie.
Also jeder sammelt irgendwie ein und dann äh geht das sozusagen auf die nächste höhere Ebene. So und einer kriegt dann irgendwie von zehn Leuten irgendwie das Geld und du gehst aber weiter und du musst ja nur dann die anderen auch noch dazu,
Also wirklich,
blöd, blöd, blöd, blöd und wenn man auch nur einmal drüber nachdenkt, richtig,
ja oder glaubst irgendeine Story drumherum, wie gesagt, ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, wie wie mir das überhaupt passiert ist, ne. Und dann bin ich da irgendwie mein Geld losgeworden und dachte so ja, jetzt muss ich ja nur noch irgendwie zu meinen Freunden laufen und dann irgendwie als ich dieses,
Gedanken in meinem Kopf hatte, wusste ich ja dann auch schon sofort, dass das dass das Spiel für mich aus war,
die Vorstellung jetzt zu meinen Freunden zu rennen,
Die dann da irgendwie in so ein Ding reinzuziehen, wo sie dann im Zweifelsfall genau in der selben Situation bin wie ich grade. Ja?
Also ich habe mich so geschämt. Es war es war so furchtbar, so grauenhaft, also ich hatte wirklich einen echt schlechten Tag. Gar nicht so sehr wegen dieses Geldes,
einfach glaube ich nur wegen dieser Blödheit, die ich in dem Moment an den Tag gelegt habe. Und.
Dieselbe Nummer sieht man einfach jetzt rund um diesen ganzen,
Blockchain-Hype, weil am Ende ist diese Blockchain nix dolles. Das ist halt,
eine technische Lösung, mit der man ein einspezifisches Problem gelöst hat, nämlich wie man so eine selbst erzeugendes Geldsystem bauen kann.
Wo man sicherstellen kann, dass man irgendwie aus dem System selber heraus.
Ohne dass sich einer gleich alles schnappt. Und damit einer sich nicht alles schnappt, sondern dass es irgendwie klar ist, wer sich jetzt was schnappt,
dadurch,
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, wie viel du deine Maschine glühen lassen kannst und wenn wir messen irgendwie, wie viel alle jetzt die Maschinen glühen lassen kann und wenn wenn dein Rechner da genug Strom verbraucht hat, so dann das kannst du ja nicht beliebig steigern und das lässt sich irgendwie messen.
So und nach diesem Prinzip funktioniert das und dann waren irgendwie alle ganz begeistert und am Anfang war das halt so eine Technologie, wo man so dachte so.
Ja, ganz interessant, keine Ahnung, wat dat jetzt irgendwie wird, so ob da irgendwas draus kommt. Vielleicht entwickelt sich das irgendwie weiter und so. Hat sich aber nicht weiterentwickelt.
Es ist halt irgendwie so eine Bubble übrig geblieben, die dann die ganze Zeit dann da weiter dran rumgedoktert hat und irgendwie die Dollarzeichen im Auge gehabt hat und als es dann halt irgendwie anfing, dass man damit Drogen kaufen konnte.
Dann kurze Zeit später eben auch gegen Dollar tauschen konnte, also andersrum sozusagen erst könnte man sozusagen Bitcoin kaufen,
indem man so echtes Geld dahin gibt und dann konnte man damit Drogen kaufen. Also ja geil hier voll anonym Internet und so weiter her mit den Drogen, dann lief das irgendwie eine Weile und damit war dann so die Zündschnur gelegt und dann kam sie halt auf immer wildere Ideen.
Wollten dann äh das irgendwie immer noch mehr machen und auf einmal bekam durch diese Exchanges das Ganze auf einmal so einen Wert
dann halt auch stieg und der stieg aber vor allem,
gar nicht so sehr durch die große Nachfrage, sondern wie man heute weiß, einfach auch durch einfach Tricks dieser Exchanges, die diese Preise halt einfach mal hochgedreht haben, weil das war ja eigentlich in dem Sinne noch kein richtiger Markt
Auf einmal wirkte das alles wertvoll. Dann also oh geil, wenn ich mir jetzt was kaufe, dann ist es irgendwie nächste Woche mehr Geld wert. Und das ist dann genauso dieser Moment
wo dann eben alle anfangen zu glühen.
Ja, das ist so der Klassiker des Internet-Scamps. So das steht einfach auf diesem ganzen
Projekt oben drauf und diese ganze Szene, die sich da jetzt äh gebildet hat und die auch alle alle Züge von so einer religiösen
Gemeinschaft prägt, indem sie so mit ihrer eigenen Sprache und ihren eigenen Mantras äh arbeitet, ja und und alle abstraft, die nicht irgendwie in ihrer Denkwelt verfangen, ja.
Die äh wenn sie geordnete Kritik äußern, dann so ja du verstehst das ja alles gar nicht äh das so abtun.
Verbergen sich halt hinter dieser Komplexität dieser ganzen kryptografischen Technikwelt und äh,
pumpen jetzt immer mehr Interesse darein, weil sie halten ja jetzt alle ihre Bitcoins oder ihre Isar oder welches Krypto-Ding das auch äh äh immer ist und wollen jetzt alle reich werden.
Sagen das natürlich nicht so direkt, sondern sie sagen.
Das sagen wir schon.
Ihr könnt alle reich werden, ne? Ja, nee, sie sagen den anderen sagen sie, ihr könnt alle reich werden,
Ihr müsst nur jetzt kurz Geld reingeben, dann werdet ihr reich. Ja, genau wie bei diesen Pyramidensystem, wo ich da irgendwie meine tausend Mark versenkt habe. Aber es sind nicht die anderen, die reich werden.
Die Leute, die da drin sind, die wollen reich werden. Die wollen, dass das, was sie da jetzt haben,
Wollen Sie irgendwie, das ist mehr wert wird und deswegen holen Sie jetzt immer mehr Leute rein und das hat eine Weile wunderbar verfangen, weil das so in dieser Nerdszene dann auf einmal so voll ja alle meinen jetzt mit und alle machen irgendwie mit und
der Preis steigt ja immer noch.
Gab's immer mal wieder so ein paar Peaks und dann kamen halt immer mehr, aber irgendwann war ein Nördland dann auch abgegrast. So also die Zahl von von so Computeraffinen Leuten, die irgendwie den ganzen Scheiß am Anfang technisch interessant fanden und dann einfach losgebrannt äh sind, als sie gemerkt haben, dass dass ihre Bits, die sie da auf ihrer Festplatte verwalten, ist auf einmal echtes Geld sein.
Wert sein.
Haben sie sich gesagt, geil, Pizza. War das Geld wieder weg?
Ja da haben sie erstmal ein bisschen mit Pizza und Burger und so weiter und halt auch diese ganze Traumwelt eines unabhängigen Finanzsystems und und und
äh vor allem loben sie jetzt diese diese Technik, die sich seit 12 Jahren nicht weiterentwickelt, nennenswert. Loben sie halt irgendwie äh hoch und erzählen irgendwas von, das wäre ja eine totale Zukunftstechnologie.
Warum denn eigentlich? Äh warum was soll denn da so sein? Ja in der Zukunft wird es ja auch alle anders funktionieren und in der Zukunft werden wir ja alle Probleme gelöst haben und in der Zukunft werden wir nicht mehr irgendwie so viel Strom verbrauchen wie äh
und Brasilien zusammen, sondern in der Zukunft wird ja alles toll und jetzt werden wir alle reich. So, aber
Man merkt jetzt gerade in den letzten Monaten so ungefähr so seit einem Jahr läuft das irgendwie ab. Jetzt jetzt wird es sozusagen,
Ähm jetzt brauchen sie neue Leute, die da Geld reintragen, damit eben diese Wertsteigerung auch weiter realisiert werden kann.
Also muss man jetzt irgendwie Leute nachholen und ähm das Problem mit diesem ganzen Kryptogeld ist vor allem erstmal das,
Es ist ja alles nix wert. Es sind ja alles nur Bits. Es ist halt nicht mehr,
Es wird auch nicht mehr als das. Es hat keinen Wert. Man kann damit nix kaufen, niemand,
erzeugt Produkte irgendwie und und und bezahlt
und verdient mit mit diesem Kryptogeld
richtigen Währung. Man kann's dafür auch nicht benutzen, weil's dafür viel zu langsam ist. Weil's irgendwie ewig dauert, bis so eine Transaktion abgeschlossen ist und dafür vor allem ein eine eine sinnlose Menge an Energie verbrannt wird,
jede Sekunde einfach tonnenweise Elektroschrott auch noch produziert wird und es einfach überhaupt nicht ähm ökonomisch,
äh haltbar wäre, weil es einfach viel zu langsam ist und und und und den Wert nicht hält äh dabei sehr viel CO2 und äh Schrott erzeugt.
Völlig unökonomisch,
nur weil aber dieses Pyramidenversprechen da draußen ist, dass es ja dann alles nochmal im Wert steigt, sind alle bereit immer noch mehr Geld da reinzupumpen und so,
bläst sich diese ganze Blase einfach auf. Und am Ende muss man einfach klar sehen, ein System, was in sich keinen Wert hat.
Kann nur dadurch mehr wert werden, indem von außen neue Leute dazugeben, die richtiges Geld da rein tun. Das ist ein,
Man könnte er einerseits sagen, es ist ein Nullsummenspiel, ja, weil da wird nie mehr Geld entstehen, da werden keine Werte geschaffen. Da sind keine Firmen, die irgendwie Produkte machen, die Mehrwert machen oder irgendwas, sonst ist es. Einfach nur Bits.
Und die,
andere Problematik ist, dass trotzdem um dieses ganze System aufrechtzuerhalten. Das ist ja nicht wie Gold das kauft so und dann liegt das irgendwie rum und verbraucht keinen Strom, sondern nein, da müssen Computer die ganze Zeit nicht nur betrieben werden, sondern auch
gekauft und weggeschmissen werden. Das kostet Geld. Das die Ressourcen dafür, die Energie, die kannst du auch nicht in Bitcoin kaufen,
sondern die kaufst du dann halt in richtigen Dollarn. Also musst du auch noch teilweise deine Bitcoins in richtiges Geld umsetzen, um das Ganze finanzieren zu können. Das heißt, das Geld, was da reingeht, das das diffundierte auch wieder heraus. Also es ist ein Negativsummenspiel. Es wird keinen Wert erzeugt
aber es wird die ganze Zeit Wert rausgenommen und deswegen funktioniert das alles nur
in dem immer mehr Leute immer mehr Geld da rein pumpen und da jetzt irgendwie die Nerds jetzt irgendwie alle durch sind und das ganze Finanzsystem und alle,
und Betrüger irgendwie sind irgendwie alle schon am Pool. So und jetzt brauchen sie halt neue Kohle und was macht man dann? Dann geht man in die Öffentlichkeit. Dann schaltet man Plakate.
Werbung holt sich irgendwelche bekloppten, voll durchgedrehten Filmstars und setzt sie in irgendwelche Talkshows und dann reden sie über den Quatsch. Aber damit dadurch, dass man irgendwie über normalen Quatsch nicht reden kann, gibt's jetzt irgendwie diese kimmere,
NFT, ja, was am Ende
irgendwas repräsentieren sollen, was am Ende nur so ein Link auf irgendeine Webseite ist, die vielleicht morgen schon wieder down ist und dann ist da gar nichts mehr zu sehen. Und alle glauben, das wäre jetzt irgendwie was mit Wert. Alle glauben, es hätte irgendwas mit Kunst zu tun oder was auch ich, was auch immer sie glauben. Hauptsache sie glauben irgendwas.
Sächlich glauben Sie alle daran, dass Sie morgen alle reich sind.
Und deswegen wird jetzt immer mehr Kohle reingemacht und jeder Fußballverein und und und sogar die Unicef und irgendwie World Wide Life Fund
also wirklich da da fasst man sich ja wirklich an den Kopf ja kommen auf einmal mit so einem äh NFT-Kram raus.
Weil man äh offensichtlich da auch überhaupt nicht mehr checkt, was was überhaupt noch Phase ist. Also musst dir echt mal vorstellen, so ein WWF ja ja wir wollen die Welt retten, indem wir irgendwie äh ganz viel Energie verbrauchen.
Toll, geil, super Idee, wer hat euch denn beraten? Kommt mal klar.
Oh, es regt mich einfach maßlos auf und mit diesem Unsinn muss jetzt einfach langsam mal äh Schluss sein. Es geht einfach gar nicht.
NFTs sind ja äh also gewissermaßen äh schon fast bewundernswert genial, ne, weil äh damit eine eine schöne, neue Möglichkeit geschaffen wurde, wie du wirklich,
nichts,
Das müssen den ja irgendwann einmal in US-Dollar oder Euro tauschen. Das heißt, du du gibst jetzt quasi Leuten IFA.
Damit Sie damit eine NFT kaufen, also wieder anderen Leuten IFA geben,
Ja und dieser NFT ist quasi die Vernichtung von von Geld, ja, ist also ein Nichtwert. Das Ding will keiner haben, potenziell möchte das mal irgendjemand, kauft ihr jemanden NFT ab? Bisher äh haben aber also du machst nicht Geld, indem du einen
NFT kaufst,
Du machst Geld, indem du eine NFT erstellst und den verkaufst, ja und diejenigen, die jetzt sagen, geil, ich kaufe den, weil der bestimmt irgendwann mehr wert ist,
äh deren Annahmen werden halt nochmal auf die Probe gestellt, ja, aber insofern ist also die wenn man sich da ein bisschen mit auseinandersetzt, das also das NFT war ja einfach nur,
glaube LFTs konnten nur entstehen.
Weil es keinen anderen Markt gab außer also niemand anders gab, der deine Bitcoin haben wollte, außer.
Drogenhändler und Elon Musk
um um halt mal wieder einen Pumpe Damm zu machen, ja. Aber sonst wollte niemand deine Dinger haben, aber wenn du jetzt sagst, hier ey Künstler,
passt mal auf, verkauft doch eure, jetzt könnt ihr endlich digitale Kunst verkaufen, ne? Ähm und und dann entsteht auf einmal wieder so ein Hype und dann kannst du halt richtig schön mal wieder
Iser verkaufen und gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm. Irgendwann müssen ja alle, die oben in der Pyramide sind, auch mal diesen Gewinn realisieren. Und das war ja, das ist ja glaube ich oder das ist das Problem Jena, die oben
an der Pyramide stehen und jetzt was weiß ich IFA oder Bitcoin in in,
von mir aus im Millionenbereich ist.
Würden Sie den Wert von IFA auf null bringen, weil keiner so viel IFA haben will, ja? Ähm
also weil die Nachfrage daran zu gering ist. Das heißt, sie müssen mehr Nachfrage schaffen, um ihren IFA, ihre IFA-Mängel quasi tranchenweise abverkaufen zu können
und äh Sie wissen, hm, wer kauft Isa? Na ja, Leute, denen du versprichst, das wird mehr wert. Und.
Damit werben ja dann auch, wenn du jetzt für die diese Werbung anschaust von diesen Exchanges hier, Krypto dot com oder sowas, ne? Die werben ja quasi auch damit, dass sie sagen, wer vor zehn Jahren,
für eintausend Euro Bitcoin gekauft hat, ist heute, dem gehört heute, was weiß ich, Holland oder so was, ne. Ähm,
und was stell dir nur vor, wie's in den nächsten zehn Jahren ist, ja? Interessanterweise haben die sich aber nicht entschieden mit ihrem Geld zu sagen, komm wir kaufen
Bitcoin und warten zehn Jahre, sondern die haben sich entschieden zu sagen, lass uns mal einen Exchange machen
ja und äh das erinnert mich an dieses schöne Ding, ne? Wenn wenn Goldrausch ist,
ja? Und das ist halt äh glaube ich auch wirklich äh bei diesen Exchanges halt sehr, sehr schön zu sehen. Gleichzeitig schwimmen die ja echt in der Kohle. Die haben ja alle irgendwelche Flipper, hast du da einen Überblick äh also es es ist ja wirklich,
täglich.
Eine eine eine Schwachstelle hat und mal wieder 300 Millionen US-Dollar irgendwo ähm einem äh einem kaputten Vorlup
zum Opfer fallen, so ungefähr
es auch nicht lange dauert, bis wieder irgend so ein Exchange aufgemacht wird und da wieder irgendwie eine eine fantastische Summe rausgetragen wird und diese Exchange ist aber eigentlich in der Lage sind, weil sie halt sehr viel größere Summen haben und,
sich eben in einer Pyramide befinden, äh sehr elegant mit diesen Verlusten äh teilweise noch umzugehen, ne. Hast du da irgendwie einen Blick drauf?
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Webseite, die diese gesamten Summen äh aufsummiert und äh,
das ist.
Ah, die habe ich ja ja, die kenne ich.
Da kann er kannst du runterscrollen und da werden halt äh einzelne Ereignisse dann aufgelistet,
dann wird der Betrag Geld, der da irgendwie verbrannt äh wurde oder verloren gegangen ist, halt immer weiter aussumiert und du scrollst weiter, bist du in Millionen Milliarden. Es ist äh komplett absurd,
Da ist übrigens auch die ID Wallet drin aufgelistet in auf der Seite.
Ein wichtiger äh wichtiger, weiterer Begriff, den man jetzt auch mal auf die Kette kriegen muss, ne, weil jetzt sozusagen diese dieses Heilsversprechen, das muss ja jetzt aufrecht erhalten werden und diese NFT-Geschichte, die funktioniert zwar jetzt gerade ganz gut, aber die hat nicht wirklich so einen langfristigen,
und die ist irgendwie.
Nee, weißt du was, Tim? Weißt du was? Ich habe ich ich muss mich jetzt leider und jemand, der jetzt zu weit wird, sich jetzt sehr ärgern, ne? Aber weißt du, wie du diese NFT-Sache als nächstes ähm.
Also wie du mehr Leute dazu bringst NFTs zu kaufen?
Ist das Eine, ne? Aber denk mal an Immobilien.
Und du steigst im Wert.
Also es werden jetzt langsam die ganzen,
Instrumente in diesem Bereich nacherfunden und das eine ist natürlich okay, du kaufst ein NFT das NFT steigt im Wert oder verliert nicht seinen vollständigen Wert. Du verkaufst es weiter und was möchtest du möchtest du noch machen?
Vermieten.
Vermieten wird das nächste große Ding, dass sie dir nämlich sagen, pass auf, du du du kaufst dir jetzt hier irgendein digitales Gut im irgend 'ne
Axt bei World of Warcraft oder wat auch immer, ja? Aber in der Zeit, wo du selber nicht spielst, kannst du die vermieten.
Und was hat das für Konsequenz? Du hast einmal die Leute, die mehr Geld reinpumpen, weil sie wissen, das kann ich ja vermieten und dann die anderen Leute, die Geld reinpumpen, um es zu mieten.
Ja? Das heißt, es ist also eine ziemlich gute Idee, um weiterhin eine Nachfrage an dieser Währung ähm herbeizuführen.
Ja
Also die die Liste an Scamps ist halt irgendwie äh unendlich vor allem kann man jetzt auch alles nochmal reimplementieren, was äh im echten Finanzsektor in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren schon alles schon mal verboten wurde. Weil hier ist ja gar nix reguliert.
Das ist ja einfach wildläufig und ähm
Der nächste Begriff, der halt jetzt so im Raum hängt, ist halt, wir haben's gerade schon äh erwähnt mit dieser mit dieser Webseite, web three, ja? So das ist ja so diese Behauptung
nachdem wir irgendwie Web 20 haben ja wir erinnern uns und das Internet wurde benutzbar, es gab Blogs et cetera, man konnte irgendwie User-Generated Content machen. Das war ja mehr so eine kulturelle Einordnung, ja. Lautet eben jetzt die Proklamation, ja jetzt kommt ja die Zukunft überhaupt mit Blockchain und so
drei. Das ist jetzt das nächste große Ding. Und das ist also genauso so eine absolute so absolutes Null-Versprechen, das irgendwie
keinerlei Substanz hat
Ja und äh abgesehen davon, dass das so nicht existent ist, dass es so ein leeres Versprechen ist, dass es auf eine völlig.
Unterskalierende total überteuerte Infrastruktur wie diese Blockchain zurückgreift, ja, für die wir irgendwie,
den Energieverbrauch von kompletten Staaten nochmal reinvestieren müssen,
steckt da einfach auch Ideologie drin, die nicht gesund ist. Es ist diese Vorstellung von alles ist irgendwie.
Finanzen ausdruckbar. Alles hat irgendwie einen Wert, alles kann besessen, vermietet, gemietet werden, alles ist irgendwie
hat eine Identität, die man kaufen kann, alles wird muss von irgendjemanden besessen werden.
Und das das das durch durch läuft dieses ganze Ding und es ist halt auch
Kein Wunder, dass äh in dieser ganzen Blockchain Kryptogeldwelt ist einfach nur so von so libertären Politikern und jetzt äh neuerdings äh springen jetzt auch noch die US äh äh Republikaner drauf auf, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Leute da auch Geld rein äh stecken, dann bist du halt schnell bei so omonösen,
wie diesem Peter Thiel, der irgendwie schon Facebook groß gemacht hat und so weiter. Also die Liste ist
unendlich lang und das ist einfach ein Ort, äh mit dem will man einfach nix zu tun haben und der ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch gefährlich.
Das ist einfach nicht gut, was da jetzt grade äh passiert.
Äh mittlerweile formiert sich auch der Widerstand und er formiert sich auch ähm zum Beispiel bei den Zentralbanken.
Also dass die in den Widerstand gehen, war ja klar. Ne also ich meine auf die ist es ja der zentrale Angriff.
Ja gut, aber es hat eine Weile gedauert, bis sich das jetzt auch wirklich formiert hat. Also jetzt wird es halt auch sichtbar. Jetzt jetzt finden Dinge statt.
Mh ja.
Also es wird nicht mehr lange dauern bis bis weitere Regulierungen,
angestrengt werden, aber es es wird halt ein ein ein gerade in den USA wieder so ein politischer Kampf zwischen äh Links und Rechtswehren.
Aber vor allem muss das Netz eben auch kulturell einfach mal mal mitkommen und sich von diesem ganzen Unsinn nicht äh überrollen lassen.
Es ist also ich ich bin ja also ich hatte ja schon mal vor einiger Zeit in der Sendung gesagt so es wird auf jeden Fall nicht gut enden
ja? Also entweder wird das alles irgendwann platzen oder dass das das überholt halt wirklich wieder den den Start und die
Möglichkeiten werden zu spät gezogen und so weiter und dann haben wir halt eine Welt äh in der wir keine Steuern mehr erheben in der Korruption nicht mehr kontrolliert werden kann, in der äh ja halt einfach ne,
so ein richtiger Turbokapitalismus dann einfach läuft und wir nirgendwo mehr Kontrollmöglichkeiten haben
ebenfalls eine schlechte ein schlechtes Ergebnis, denke ich. Ähm ich weiß nicht genau, in welche der beiden Optionen es sein wird
Gleichzeitig ähm.
Würde ich zumindest den technischen Teil immer von der von der gesellschaftlichen Komponente noch versuchen zu trennen und was mir gerade mehr Sorgen macht,
Also die technische ist natürlich besorgniserregend, ja. Aber was mir gerade mehr Sorgen macht, ist eigentlich, was da gesellschaftlich passiert, weil wenn solche Blasen, solche Pyramiden, Schemata, äh solche Hypes entstehen, ja? Jetzt.
Kommen ja erst die richtigen Leute. Ja, was nämlich also was hm,
was jetzt die in den letzten Jahrzehnt passiert ist, war irgendwie so eine Sache von,
klein eingeschworenen Kreis, ja, die dann irgendwann feststellen, okay es gibt äh es werden wilde Summen für,
Bitcoins bezahlt oder so, ja? Und ich hab's mal probiert, habe das Geld wirklich bekommen, ja? Und aber jetzt wird ja erst so richtig
Kessel angemacht, ne? Krypto dot com und wie sie alle heißen und die.
Die werden schon also die werden natürlich schon ungefähr,
sagen wir mal aufm Schirm haben, wie hoch das Ding noch geritten wird und ich gehe davon aus, dass ähm bevor das alles platzt.
Noch noch ganz andere Summen an an Bitcoin und stehen werden und noch ganz andere,
Menschengruppen motiviert werden, da Geld reinzukippen.
Eben und immer erst dann.
Bereit sind zu platzen, wenn keine Sau mehr dran glaubt. Ja, wenn der wenn keiner mehr zu finden ist,
ähm der noch mehr Geld ausgibt und dann geht irgendeiner hin und sagt, ich würde gerne sehen, ja und dann platzt das Ganze in sich zusammen und davon sind wir noch so weit entfernt,
ist auf die eine Weise, also noch könnte man das stoppen, ja? Ich find's wirklich beobachte, dass.
Ist ist das ein äh Finanzanlagetipp jetzt noch einzusteigen und noch mitzugehen?
Nehmen Sie jetzt noch mal alles mit, was ich machen. Es soll noch ist es nicht so weit.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber also es ist klar, dass also dieses ähm.
Oder äh das wird mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit platzen. Ähm dann gibt es Blut in den Straßen, aber das wird erst dann passieren, wenn wirklich,
wenn es äh wenn das Risiko systemisch ist, ja? Solange das noch also und und dass es wirklich
alle mitgespielt haben, ne? Also schau dir an, wie wie halt die die Blasen, die jetzt so historisch
du so hattest, ne, die reißen dann wirklich immer auf so eine komplette Volkswirtschaft oder sogar eine Weltökonomie in den Keller, weil alle ihren Scheiß da reingekippt haben.
Und das wird halt bei ähm also was ja momentan, wenn du dir die ähm diese Erträge anschaust, ist einfach eine Tatsache.
Das Beste, was du mit Geld in den letzten zehn Jahren machen konntest, war, dass in irgendwelche Kryptowährungen zu kippen,
Ja? Über beliebige Zeiträume, Wahnsinnserträge und das wird ähm diese Geschichte werden natürlich noch viele Leute glauben hören und äh wiederholen wollen und die wird sich auch noch ein äh noch,
über einen definierten Zeitraum wiederholen, bis dann irgendwann
alle sagen
das dauert halt bis so eine also eine Blase hat halt wirklich die Platze erst dann, wenn es wirklich so ein,
wirklich systemisches Risiko ist ja die gesamte Volkswirtschaft da drin hängt und dann irgendwann irgendein komisches Ereignis ist, was darstellt oder was abbildet. Ach so scheiße. Hm,
Wenn man jetzt mal sehen möchte, dann kommt gar nix und dann hast du.
Dann hast du auch noch ein ganz anderes Problem, wenn du so ein Bankgun hast, ne. Dann geht der,
bei Ethereum und dann werden die Transaktionen total langsam, weil diese Blockchain, die es hier in der Lage eine gewisse Anzahltransaktionen irgendwie pro Zeiteinheit zu verarbeiten,
die Transaktionsgebühren gehen dann komplett durch die Decke und ah es ist halt alles nicht schön, auch auf einer technischen Ebene.
Wunderschön, dass du das gerade machst. Das ist hier noch gar nicht so besprochen. Der ist es passen nur so und so viele definierte Transaktionen pro Zeiteinheit in den Block und äh in die Auswahl,
wer in den Block kommt.
Der Bitcoinpreis gerade sehr hoch oder sehr tief äh
schnellt und viele sagen oh oh ich muss jetzt eine Transaktion durchführen, dass die halt einfach nicht mehr stattfindet.
Ja, das ist einfach so. Du du musst dann quasi ich biete die Hälfte meines Gewinnes dafür, dass ich ihn realisieren kann, ne.
Und du hast äh auch heutzutage immer wieder mal so Gas-Wash äh auf der Atherian Blockchain, wo sich dann irgendwelche Aktoren äh gegenseitig äh die die Preise für für so eine Einheit, die man braucht um Transaktionen durchzuführen. Äh einfach wahnsinnig
künstlich in die Höhe treiben so. Also äh mein Bauchgefühl ist so, dass das hier einfach nur äh Kapitalismus äh mit
äh anderen Werkzeugen ist so und der ganze Rand, den ich gerade eben gehört habe, den könnte man auch genauso über den Kapitalismus abhalten so, ne. Das hat alles irgendwie einen Wert,
bekommt, dass man alles irgendwie besitzen, kaufen, mieten oder sich äh irgendwie keine Ahnung äh beleihen kann. Ähm das das funktioniert auch im Kapitalismus so.
Ich finde das äh und äh also da hast du natürlich vollkommen recht und das Schöne ist eigentlich, dass ähm.
Wenn du jetzt so mit mit Leuten redest, die dir sagen, oh ja hier aber äh Smart contract oder Bitcoin hast du alles nicht gesehen, dass das Leute sind, die häufig,
Ich bin ist es ein bisschen gemein.
Antikapitalistische äh Idealvorstellung haben und in Wahrheit da eigentlich.
Genau. Irgendeine Antikapitalistische Idealvorstellung haben und
ja und dann stehen die da und sagen, äh ja, du kannst aber jetzt hier.
Liebe Notare, ihr seid die Ersten und Notainnen natürlich auch. Ihr seid die Ersten, die ich ersetze durch eine Blockchain und einen Python-Script,
ja? Sobald es geht aber also das ist so die eine die eine Gruppe, wo ich jetzt echt keine keine Schwierigkeiten hätte mhm die loszuwerden.
Also die äh umzuschulen ähm aber äh.
Es es gibt halt schon Gründe, warum man das hat, ja und jetzt irgendwie dieses Smart Contracts sind ja sowieso der Obergag, weißt du, ich meine wenn du wenn jetzt irgendwie die Verträge,
zu denen, für die wir zu Notan gehen. Ja, die sind ja wenigstens noch in unserer Muttersprache formuliert,
Ja und die können uns dann die können uns irgendwie erklärt werden. Die Verträge, die Leute jetzt in irgendwelchen Blockchains und Daars machen,
Die verstehen sie, sie verstehen ja noch nicht mal, was IFA ist. Es es erst recht verstehen die nicht in einen Smart Contract, der in irgendeiner kruden Programmiersprache äh gesprochen äh geschrieben ist, die sie nicht verstehen.
Und also ich glaube nicht, dass da gerade für irgendjemanden.
Sei mal nennenswerte Vorteile gegenüber des Systems äh entstehen.
Unter dem Sie jetzt grade leiden, nur dass hier jetzt mal und das ist ja der das Entscheidende von solchen äh Systemen, das hier jetzt mal äh erklärt äh oder versprochen wird, dass du ein schönes Stück vom Kuchen abkriegst.
Also wir werden
über dieses Thema leider noch sehr oft reden müssen so, aber es ist halt einfach echt mal jetzt auch äh an der Zeit hier mal äh Stellung zu beziehen, weil das ist einfach nix Gutes, was da grade,
kommt und klar, man kann da jetzt irgendwie noch ein bisschen reich werden, aber man kann aber auch wirklich eine ganze Menge Geld da verlieren.
Sie werden alle reich, wenn alle reicht. Das ist doch das Schöne.
Ja, ja.
Hier auf diesem Referral Link.
Ja am Schluss, am am Schluss gehen wir natürlich dann auch nochmal das NFT raus irgendwie mit dem Logbuchnetzpolitik-Logo. Nein. Das machen wir natürlich nicht, ne. Also äh vielleicht,
an der Stelle jetzt auch erstmal äh abschließen. Zwei
Sache möchte ich euch auf jeden Fall noch empfehlen, wenn ihr Lust habt, euch das nochmal so ein bisschen äh tiefer reinzubringen, gibt's einerseits den sehr schönen Text von äh Tante, das dritte Web, der irgendwie diesen ganzen Komplex auch nochmal
in Ruhe äh aufdröselt. Das gibt's jetzt mittlerweile auch in Deutsch ursprünglichen englischer äh Blog äh Beitrag.
Lesenswert,
das Video, was man sich jetzt auf jeden Fall mal in Ruhe geben sollte, vielleicht sogar auf halber Geschwindigkeit oder zumindest zwei oder drei Mal anschauen, auch wenn es irgendwie über zwei Stunden lang ist, aber ihr werdet es nicht bereuen. Leinen goes ab,
the problem with äh NFTs, das ist so ein Video von den Olsen, der ohnehin einer der
exzellentesten Naratoren irgendwie in diesem Netz äh ist, der sich schon zu sehr vielen interessanten Themen
geäußert hat und ähm jetzt eigentlich so sein Meisterwerk
geliefert hat mit diesem Video, wo er wirklich also diese vollständige Herleitung mit was ist das überhaupt für eine Technologie, womit haben wir das mit zu tun? Was sind die Implikationen, was läuft da alles falsch damit? Ähm sehr
dicht und sehr äh prägnant auch nochmal äh erzählt.
Das habt ihr euch sicherlich auch alle schon zweimal angeschaut oder?
Ich hab's äh immer mal wieder laufen lassen, ja.
Klare Empfehlung, auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist äh ganz toll und wenn wenn euch das äh gefallen hat, schaut euch auch gleich noch äh das das Zweite
Video an also er hat mehrere Videos er kommt ja eigentlich aus dem Filmbereich so den Ölsen aber ist halt einfach so ein so ein Komplexitäts äh Versteher und ähm wenn euch das gefallen hat, was äh auch noch ganz hervorragend äh ist, ist äh in Search of a Flat Earth,
dass es auch ein eine sehr interessante Analyse, die tatsächlich weniger mit Flat Earth äh zu tun hat als vielmehr auch eine Betrachtung gesellschaft
Entwicklung ist. Äh mehr will ich da mal nicht verraten. Ähm,
Einstieg. Aber es wird jetzt einfach mal Zeit, dass man sich hier mal irgendwie informiert und unaufgeregt über diesen ganzen Kram äh aufhält. Und da sind wir ja die Experten, ne? Unaufgeregte Diskussionen.
Und dann vorsichtig ganz vorsichtig aufhören zu hodeln, ja.
Äh
Gut.
Ganz langsam,
Sache, die sie tun können,
dafür werben, dass andere ihnen ihre Coins abkaufen, ne. Es ist.
Na ich hole noch ein bisschen. Kurs ziehen hunderttausend bei Bitcoin.
So kommen wir kommen wir zu unserer geliebten Bundesregierung, die hat nämlich was Tolles geschafft, was noch keiner geschafft hat und dafür muss man ja mal wirklich also ich weiß nicht, ob man sie dafür loben muss, aber man kann sie auf jeden Fall mal erwähnen, ja.
Na ja, also Sie haben sicher, wir hatten's, glaube ich, letzte Mal schon erzählt, also die.
Und ähm.
Ich stelle mir das ja so vor, dass da jemand so Google aufgemacht hat und und da Telegram eingegeben hat.
Nee, ich glaube, also wer ich ich ich stelle mir das tatsächlich so vor, wir hatten ja, also wir haben's ja hier schon äh immer berichtet, dass dass Apple und Google offenbar.
Ihre,
der Kanal,
der wird auf unseren Geräten nicht mehr angezeigt, sonst fliegt die App aus dem Store. Und äh das ist ja das, was wir auch hier beobachtet haben. Beispielsweise Attila Hildmanns, Kanäle, die dann eben,
aufm iPhone nicht mehr zu sehen waren oder hier ähm Rate Forums und was ich alles, ne.
Und wahrscheinlich hat irgendjemand bei Google gesehen, dass die deutsche,
NFTler geht. Entschuldigung, ich sage genug äh NFT-Gewäsche. Ähm und dann wird irgendjemand gesagt haben, ja hallo, ich wollte nur sagen.
Hier in wahrscheinlich in dieser Telegram-Gruppe reicht hier Telegram und ähm nun,
beobachtet man, dass es äh oder gab es dann erstmals den Bericht, dass jetzt die deutschen Behörden mit Telegram in Austausch waren.
Und jetzt findest du äh ich glaube Attila Hildmanns Kanal ist eines der Beispiele, wo dann nicht nur auf einem Android,
Telefon oder nicht nur aus in einer Telegram-App aus dem Google Play Store, sondern auch aus einem
und außerdem auch auf der Webseite von Telegram selber und in deren App die jetzt was weiß ich nicht Plattformen Store gebunden ist drin steht dieser Kanal wird aufgrund lokaler
geltender Gesetze nicht angezeigt. Ja, das heißt, Attila Hildmann muss jetzt ähm.
Nicht-deutsche vom Deutschen Reich überzeugen.
Zugänglich ist.
Ich glaube auch, dass wir bisher nur eine Sperrung in Deutschland gesehen haben, also zumindest in der Schweiz, weiß ich, geht's noch und Österreich nehme ich jetzt mal an, auch noch.
Hab's ihm nicht weiter angeschaut. Ich habe mit Telegram bisher nur in einer Hinsicht Spaß gehabt. Ich laufe gerade virtuell um das, um den Bundestag herum und will mal gucken, es gibt ja diese Möglichkeit, Leute um sich,
zu entdecken und äh mal gucken, ob irgendwelche Politiker in diesen äh rechten Gruppen mit unterwegs sind. Der ist ja bald wieder Sitzungswoche, vielleicht haben das ja so ein paar AFD-Politiker eingeschaltet, so dann kann man mal gucken.
Was für was für rechtsextremen Gruppen die so mit.
Zum Glück hört uns glaube ich keinen niemand von der AfD mehr. Insofern kann ich verraten.
Für dich.
Ja, aber ich meine, äh wenn wir jetzt mal zurückdenken hier über unsere erste äh längere Session, die wir in dem Podcast gehabt haben über Telegram, mit ähm.
Gespräch mit mit Max Hoppenstedt genau so äh da war ja noch so ein bisschen so der Stand, so Telegram redet mit niemandem und hört auf niemanden und kein Staat kann die irgendwie erreichen.
Hat äh unsere Innenministerin es offensichtlich geschafft tatsächlich einen Kanal hier zu eröffnen. Ob sie jetzt die
äh Kontaktdaten von Google oder Apple bekommen hat, keine Ahnung, beides war glaube ich im Gespräch.
Auf jeden Fall scheint es gelungen zu sein und es scheint auch gelungen zu sein. Telegram hier in gewisser Hinsicht so weit unter Druck zu setzen, dass sie gesagt haben, na ja okay, dann machen wir halt mal was.
Das ist ja schon mal äh ganz bemerkenswert.
Das ist auf jeden, also es ist auf viele Weisen bemerkenswert und ich hätte nicht auf also ist ja auch glaube ich hier dokumentiert. Wir haben im Dezember noch darüber gesprochen.
Hätte jetzt nicht auf dieses Ende getippt. Ja, also mein Eater hätte ich in einen anderen Smart Contract gewettet. Hä?
Kohle schon wieder da.
Da wäre ich also da damit also mit diesem Ergebnis habe ich nicht gerechnet. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ähm.
Also wer weiß, was sie da äh also ne, die haben offenbar sich ausgetauscht und wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele daran offenbar wie lange gescheitert sind, ist es schon überraschend. Jetzt,
ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Da bleibe ich jetzt bei den bei den Kräfteverhältnissen, die ich davor gefunden habe. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das allein mit der Überzeugungskraft von Nancy Faser irgendwie passiert ist,
äh dass die dass die gute Argumente hat oder genug Druck. Ähm ich vermute schon, dass ähm
dass da dass da irgendeine Form von Emplification dabei war, ja im Sinne von das Google und Apple gesagt haben, nee, pass auf.
Wir haben keine Lust mehr Pavel. Das sind hier den ganzen Tag bei uns landet. Du machst das jetzt, sonst äh,
Ne, wir wir halten uns an Gesetze, musst du jetzt auch machen, sonst schmeißen wir dich raus oder so. Dass da irgendeinen Hebel noch mit dran war, also dass sie irgendeine Form von Verstärkung hatte,
Davon gehe ich aus, aber.
Schon sehr äh also spannend. Hätte ich nicht mitgerechnet mit diesem Ergebnis.
Auf jeden Fall meinst du das äh ernst mit der Verfolgung von Rechtsradikalen irgendwie. Das kann man ja hier schon mal attestieren.
Entsprechend wird's ja jetzt auch von der Bildfertig gemacht, ne? Also aber auch absehbar. Wie.
Ja, wo kommen wir denn da hin.
Ähm dann gibt es eine äh es wird eine die die größte sicher und jetzt sagen wir mal die die die.
Die erfolgreichste älteste und wahrscheinlich auch teuerste Sicherheitslücke.
Ähm der letzten zweieinhalb Jahrzehnte wird jetzt von Microsoft geschlossen Tim.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, wir hatten das Thema ja schon mal.
Haben wir das letzte Mal schon besprochen.
Letzte Mal nicht,
Aber wir haben äh schon vor längerer Zeit hast du genau diese Sicherheitslücke beklagt beziehungsweise äh dich fassungslos gezeigt, wie es sein kann, dass nach so vielen Jahren dieses,
immer noch besteht. Und jetzt mit zwei, drei Jahren Verzögerung haben sie dich erhört.
Also äh ich,
es gibt ja einen Vortrag von mir, der sich damit auseinandersetzt, ist der äh Vortrag ähm Hirnehacken auf dem sechsunddreißig C drei. Ähm es ist jetzt auch nicht nur
meine Erkenntnis, dass halt Makros einfach seit seit
mehr oder weniger 1999 die großen äh Probleme sind, ja oder eben eine
oder auf jeden Fall sagen wir mal eine Erfindung die,
führt in jedem beliebigen Zeitraum und äh dass das Beste ist, dass einfach äh abzuschalten.
Und das macht Microsoft jetzt bei Defalt.
Äh man könnte eigentlich inzwischen sagen, dass es ein Vergehen gegen den gegen den Denkmalschutz im Cyber ist.
Ich mache gleich mal Slow-Clap irgendwie.
Wie viele wie viele, wie oft hast du irgendwas mit mit äh mit Office Markus gemacht? Beruflich oder in der in der freien Datenreise.
Ähm tatsächlich eher selten. Es scheint mir so das Geschäftsgebiet von Ray Service Providern zu sein so.
Ich habe das häufig äh tatsächlich auch in in äh Pantest, wenn man jetzt mal so ein ähm.
Und äh erklären musste, wie einfach das halt auslösbar ist, habe ich tatsächlich äh regelmäßig dann einfach den Angriff nochmal in Javascript gebaut und,
auch nochmal in in Office makros, äh weil das irgendwie so ein bisschen greifbarer einfach ist für diejenigen, die es sich anschauen,
A zu sehen, okay, hm, meine Firewall ist irgendwie doch nur eine Firewall und ich habe ein bisschen überschätzt, was die feiert. Und ähm zweitens,
äh hier ne diese,
diese diese äh Office-Makros sind wirklich ein Problem, schalt die mal ab. Und in in diesem Rahmen habe ich tatsächlich öfter Office Markus genutzt, allerdings auch wirklich immer nur um,
Netzwerkverbindungen, ne, also quasi um meine äh Explodes und oder Demos mal abzuliefern, weil weil was es tatsächlich mal versucht habe,
Und was ist wirklich schwierig ist, dann muss man vielleicht auch, muss man schon dazu sagen, wenn jetzt so klassisch bösartige Statements schreibst in so einen Office makro.
Äh dann hast, kriegst du echt mit diesem Windows Defender äh Probleme
Das äh da habe ich echt irgendwie Schwierigkeiten gehabt. Und jede Form von
da muss man Microsoft zumindest auch mal sagen, da haben Sie sicherlich viel investiert, um diesen Windows Defender ganz gut zu machen. Wobei, was Sie am Ende offenbar, ich habe dann auch
immer gedacht so okay krass jetzt gebe ich mir wirklich Mühe für
Wieso findet der selbst, ne, meine persönliche Trick-App-Office-Kashion? Und dann habe ich halt festgestellt, dass dass der Windows Defender für Office Markus einfach ähm,
quasi eine eine Sandbox spoint und und das Makro ausführt, ja. Also der hat gar nicht mehr Heuristiken gehabt, sondern er hat's einfach er hat einfach geguckt, was passiert.
Und damit hat es.
Macht er auf jeden Fall wesentlich weniger kaputt als nur mancher andere Schlangen wie Software, die ich mir schon mal ange.
Richtig.
Ein Ding äh ist auch äh irgendwie so so öffentlich bekannt. Äh so ein Virenscanner für Linux auch irgendwie ein Wahnsinn, dass so was überhaupt gibt. Äh.
Ähm
äh Remotey. Aber ja, äh
Nee, also mit Microsoft äh Office Produkten tatsächlich eher weniger zu tun so. Das ist eher äh bei Insulin äh interessant, weil das ist halt ein sehr häufig gewählter Einstiegspunkt so aus meiner,
aus meinem Bauchgefühl so, aus meiner subjektiven Erfahrung.
Also die das jetzt das die abzuschalten ähm ist der schwerste Schlag den äh,
erlitten haben. Ja, das ist so richtig, richtig schlimm. Das ist alles andere ist irgendwie so, hä ja okay, ne.
Mal schauen, also ich stelle mir das ich stelle mir das so vor, dass die Dokumente jetzt einfach mit einer kleinen Anleitung kommen hier um die Inhalte in diesen Dokument freizuschalten äh bitte mal hier hier und hier klicken.
Das also das werden sie natürlich.
Ob das tatsächlich was bringt.
Aber das ist also ich find's tatsächlich es ist es war einfach
Vortrag hier in der Hacken habe ich das noch ein bisschen ausführlicher auch behandelt, was es was es eben psychologisch bedeutet den Leuten eben das Wegklicken von Warnungen anzutrainieren, was es äh das niemand versteht, was ein Makro ist und ich meine, die Empirie spricht da einfach
ganz klar.
Eine ganz klare Sprache, das ist äh,
Die meisten brauchen's halt nicht und gebrauchen es auch nicht und da bei,
in diesem Bereich der Nutzerinnen sind sicherlich einfach schwere schwere Schäden äh entstanden und das ist jetzt eine sehr sehr späte äh Einsicht.
Ach ja.
Nicht einmal.
Ich habe das glaube ich seit äh.
Nicht. Ja, aber nur weil sie sich dazu gezwungen haben.
Ja
Das meinte ich ja, ist schon.
Aber es gab neulich eine
Es gab neulich eine ganz lustige äh Statistik oder Studie besser gesagt boah ich muss die raussuchen, ich ich schicke die euch noch zu. Äh wo's hieß, dass äh Office-Benutzerinnen tatsächlich,
tiefer sind, weniger Fehler machen und mehr Output produzieren als Leute, die Latteig benutzen.
Ah ja, das habe ich auch gelesen. Das glaube ich auch sofort.
Ne weil wer Latech benutzt, publiziert halt einmal im Jahr. Äh weil die vernünftig forschen. Oder? Also oder wie kommt dieser Effekt zustande?
Ich habe mir die Studie tatsächlich nicht weiter angeschaut. Ähm ich such's raus, vielleicht war's auch nur ein Tweet. Äh ihr wisst es.
Die Studie oder Tweet, ihr kennt das.
Ja. Ähm genau. Ich such's raus, äh werfe es mir noch in die Show Notes mit rein.
Flipke, du musst jetzt sagen, hast du überhaupt Lust über die verbotene App hier zu sprechen?
Äh
Ich weiß, ich habe aufgehört zu zählen, aber es gibt halt Neuigkeiten, ne.
Da musst du jetzt durch.
Oh je! Oh je!
Die Brandenburgische,
Brandenburgische Justizministerin äh hatten den Missstand erkannt, dass offensichtlich keine Rechtssicherheit gibt, dafür die Luca App Daten für die Strafverfolgung zu nutzen. Deswegen möchte sie das jetzt klären.
Also sie will spezifisch Polizei und Staatsanwälten Zugriff darauf erlauben,
und,
Das ist eine von uns. Die weiß genau,
so eine Luca App noch mal so einen mitgeben muss, ne, um
die aktuelle äh Risikokapitaleinsammelrunde noch mal zu torpedieren, den Leuten zu sagen, ey ihr wollt die App wirklich deinstallieren, ne? Das ist die die Brandenburgische Justizministerin, die weiß ganz genau, die die kämpft an unserer Seite
ja gegen gegen diese Leute. Ansonsten äh wir hatten's gerade schon erwähnt, der Personalausweis soll auch noch rein. Alter Vater,
Und äh ja.
Tickets sollten doch auch noch mit rein.
Alles muss da jetzt rein und wenn ich mir das anschaue, also ich ich guck's ja schon gar nicht mehr an, ne? Aber ich würde sagen,
mit Luca kooperiert. Das wird natürlich dafür bezahlt haben müssen. Ja, also du hast jetzt also das ist jetzt der Ausverkauf dieser Installationsbasis, ne? Es werden jetzt
neue Features werden jetzt nicht mehr selber entwickelt, sondern ne, wie das so ist bei einer Pyramide.
Die oben in der Pyramide sind. Die müssen halt auch mal irgendwann ihre äh Pyramidenanteile loswerden und das ist glaube ich das, was jetzt mit äh
Luca äh passiert, ja? Die Installationsbasis, die muss ja irgendwann gemolken werden und äh das scheint mir jetzt doch der,
der Effekt zu sein, den den wir da gerade sehen.
Geil, wenn ich jetzt ein Lieferando wäre, ich würde würde Luca hingehen und die die Fragen so so was vorsichtig haben, sodass wir hier mal noch irgendwie Pizzabestellung mit reinhacken in das in diese App.
Ja, ich denke, die werden ähm also da werden sie dir sicherlich ein Angebot machen, ne. Also werden halt sagen, na ja okay, wir haben vier
wir wir in unseren Präsentationen haben wir 3040 Millionen Installationsbasis äh hier sind unsere Zahlen, du kannst davon ausgehen, wie viel hast du?
Und dann werden wir sicherlich einen Preis finden, der letztendlich sich nur aus der Installationsbasis ableitet, ne. Das ist der, das ist ja das Einzige, was sie.
Sie jetzt wirklich haben, der Rest ist ja Murks und das ist das einzige was schwer zu bekommen ist oder eben teuer ist und da verkaufen sie halt jetzt Installationsbasis auf Smartphones in Deutschland. Das werden sie machen.
Dann gab es ein Urteil, was ähm,
Würde mich auch nochmal interessieren. Also ist ein Urteil des Landgerichts München.
Und da hatte also der Streitgegenstand war,
wegen der Weitergabe von einer IP-Adresse durch an Google,
Nutzung von Google.
Gestalten, tätig sind oder was, wissen das vielleicht nicht. Es war vor vor einiger Zeit also früher war es ein bisschen schwierig und auch gar nicht so unbedingt üblich.
Andere
und das geht dann wenn dann gab es unterschiedliche konkurrierende,
Fond-Typen-Standards, die es so ein bisschen erschwerten, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich möchte jetzt aber hier diesen Fund bei mir in der Webseite haben, also diesen Schrifttypen.
Dann musstest du den,
die Lösung, die es dafür gab, die eine funktionierte dann in dem Browser äh nicht und dafür aber in dem anderen und was nicht alles. Das war dann nicht ganz so einfach. Ja und dann kam Google daher und hat gesagt, pass auf.
Ähm ähm,
Schreibt einfach dieses Stück äh,
Code, der zu eurem Browser passt und so garantieren, dass diese schöne Schrift problemlos funktioniert. Außerdem haben wir hier eine Reihe an Schriften für euch. Die haben wir schon mal lizensiert. Die haben wir gekauft. Die dürfte dann benutzen.
Ja und das war natürlich ein sehr schönes Angebot für Menschen.
Um zu sagen, ach ja Mensch geil, es gibt hier schöne freie Schriften, die funktionieren einfach, also benutze ich das, ne? Eine Zeile,
hier,
äh source Google von dot Google dot com und fertig. Und jetzt habe ich eine schöne Schrift auf meiner Webseite. Hat natürlich rasenden Absatz gefunden und jetzt äh,
hat hier offenbar jemand gesagt, pass auf, ich besuche diese Webseite, jetzt wird aber dadurch, dass ihr in eurer Webseite drinstehen habt, Google von nachladen.
Äh ist der Effekt, dass mein Browser sich mit Google verbindet und Google kriegt dann ne, die Google Cookies und trackt mich auf eurer Webseite und das äh finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Und der hat gewonnen, denn der Beklagte wurde verurteilt an den Kläger 100 Euro zuzüglich Zinsen äh und so weiter zu bezahlen und ähm,
diese ähm und darüber Auskunft zu erteilen, was mit den personenbezogenen Daten geschehen ist und so weiter.
Das ist jetzt so ein typisches Urteil, wo die einen sagen, völliger Irrsinn, Google Fonds ist überall und das rechtliche Risiko, was jetzt für alle entsteht, da die das benutzen, ist ist.
Quasi an der Realität vorbei.
Quasi sagen, es ist in deinem Interesse, dass deine IP-Adresse hier an Google äh gegeben wird oder du diesen Googlefond lädst, weil die Webseite sieht ja schöner aus.
Ne, der weil es wäre ja ein sehr einfacher Aufwand oder sein ein überschaubarer Aufwand gewesen. Die Schriftart einfach mal selber zu horsten und äh dieses Problem,
sinnvoll zu lösen. Das ist so ein typisches äh das ist jetzt so ein DSGVO-Urteil. Äh was jetzt,
in ohne barriere Konsequenz natürlich hat, dass jetzt alle, mal die eine Webseite haben, gucken müssen, ob sie nicht irgendeinen Wordpress äh äh Plug-in haben, was Google nutzt oder so was.
Äh
Ich denke, das äh sollte sind auf jeden Fall alle gut beraten, jetzt mal zu schauen, ob sie nicht irgendwo Googlefonds noch drin haben.
Stirbt ein Business-Modell ähm.
Potenziell, ne, Fette, äh also ein fetter äh Tracking,
Ähm also ich würde sagen, Googlefonds war eine der besseren Ideen, die Google hatte, um Tracking ihre Tracking-Fühlerchen im Internet auszustrecken, ne. Google Analytics war schon immer irgendwie,
Einfacher oder war für die Leute irgendwie klar, oh nein, der Google, der ist da der,
dann da, der sieht das, was wir machen und so, ne, das ist irgendwie analytics, das finden wir unschön. Da hatte man eine einfachere Möglichkeit oder einen einfacheren Weg, sich über ähm.
Also irgendsoein Datenschutzfurcht äh.
Zu generieren und das zu skandalisieren und da ein Thema draus zu machen und Google Fonds war so, ach guck mal hier, sieht besser aus. Ja, Google Net hatte das freundliche Internet von Google, ja. Das war schon eine ziemlich gute Idee, um äh überall mal mitgeladen zu werden.
Muss man ja auch noch dazu sagen, dass sie über den Referent, der der den der Browser mit,
auch sehen im Zweifelsfall, was für ein Medikament ich mir jetzt gerade irgendwie bei DocMorris oder keine Ahnung, was für ein äh Erektionsmittel ich mir bei Beate Use online angucke.
Klar, natürlich äh.
Google weiß welche NFTs du gerade gekauft hast.
Auwei.
Mhm.
Übrigens, wo du gerade Google Analytics äh erwähnst, es kam ja auch grad noch die Meldung rein, dass die französische Datenschutz äh Aufsichtsbehörde CNIL jetzt auch irgendwie Google äh Analytics äh verboten hat.
Also da ist noch sehr viel mehr äh Ärger im äh im Anmarsch. Ähm also sie meinen halt einfach Google Analytics verstößt äh in Frankreich gegen die Datenschutzbestimmung, aber wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe, hat das auch automatisch EU-Weite Auswirkungen.
Gar nicht drauf äh es mehr abwarten bis bis Facebook endlich mal hier abschaltet und Google kann gleich mit äh seine Dienste wie Analytics mit abschalten.
Ja mal gucken, wie lange wir das dann aushalten, ne, wenn wenn kein Google läuft so, wie lange äh wie lange ist das Internet noch.
Halte das ja alles für Quatsch Quatschdrom ne von Facebook äh was was diese Datenschutzsachen angeht und
Außerdem sieht man jetzt hier mal, dass dass die DSGVO tatsächlich was bringt. Ich ich finde das äh ziemlich nice so, das was da jetzt so da drumherum gerade passiert und dass der Privacy schielt
hm ja aufgehoben wurde quasi.
Das denke ich allerdings auch.
Man kann ja Google Fonds dann irgendwie auf irgendwas mit DHM umsteigen. Das ist ja auch eine totale Zukunftstechnologie.
Äh Geschäft, nicht wahr? Also man hat ja irgendwann mal hat man ja mal teure und gut Drucker verkauft. Ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern. Habe ich viel Geld für einen Drucker ähm bezahlt und.
Echt. Du hast einen Drucker.
Jetzt.
Crazy. Das das wären das das wäre mir ja peinlich in der Öffentlichkeit zu sagen, dass ich einen Drucker habe so.
Also ich habe keinen Drucker, ich ich äh verweigere mich dieser Technologie beharrlich. Also kein 2D-Drucker. So, ich sehe das nicht ein. Wieso soll ich mir einen Drucker kaufen? So, ist doch.
Zwei.
Entschuldigung, ich bin unter dreißig. Ich äh kaufe sowas nicht. Ich finde das irgendwie dumm irgendwie Zeug auf Papier zu drucken. Wer macht das.
Mir fallen da schon ein paar Use Cases ein, also äh da habe ich jetzt keinen Mangel.
Wie willst du denn sonst? Schreibst du deine Briefe von Hand oder was.
Ich schreibe meistens E-Mails.
Aber aber Flipke, wie wie soll ich denn ohne Drucker meinen Brief ins Fox-Krieg?
Tatsächlich verwende tatsächlich äh habe ich hier ein äh Faxgerät in in meine Telefonieanlage eingebaut, weil weil ich nie keinen Drucker habe und keine Briefe versenden kann. Habe ich immerhin noch ein Faxgerät hier.
Das ist dieses moderne Zeug mit Blockchain und so weiter. Gehen wir aus der Sonne.
Also ich würde mal sagen, es gibt schon noch Use Cases für äh Drucker. Ich habe eine ganze Menge sogar und äh ich hatte schon immer gerne Drucker. Ich bin ein großer Freund von Druckern generell und,
besondere von Laserdruckern, da da habe ich äh geradezu erotische Beziehungen zu.
Tut mir leid dein King da angegriffen zu haben.
Ja, das verletzt mich auch ein bisschen, ne, aber wir können uns einigen des Tintenstrahldrucker irgendwie übel.
Weißt du wenigstens wenn du wenn du Tim eine eine Signal Nachricht schreibst äh schreibst du halt unter eine bitte denken sie nach bevor sie diese Signal.
Auf Laserdrucker, auf ihrem Tintenstrahldrucker ausdrucken
Na ja, also ich denke, es gibt äh für Drucker generell äh durchaus Bedarf, aber die Zeiten, wo man irgendwie viel Geld für einen Drucker ausgeben durfte, die sind leider vorbei.
Denn sie haben dann quasi auf das Rasierklingenmodell umgestellt und haben sich gedacht, och Drucker ist ja irgendwie mittlerweile,
relativ günstig herzustellen, also verkaufen wir die äh so.
Dass alle jetzt auch noch einen haben wollen und dann verkaufen wir ihnen den Toner richtig schön teuer.
Haben sie auch gemacht und wenn man sich so die Preise anschaut so, das ist schon schon ordentlich, ne? Entsprechend hat sich natürlich da schnell so ein Partymarkt äh drumgebildet. Die dachten da so ein paar Krümel irgendwie in so eine Metallröhre rein,
kriegen wir irgendwie auch noch hin.
Das sind doch auch wirklich so absurde also absurde Läden, die gibt es ja wirklich, die gibt's auch heute noch ne. Wie heißen die dann irgendwie
Auffüller 24.
Druckerpatronen wieder auf oder so, ne.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das noch so ist, aber die haben halt alle ihre Quellen. Die ham auf jeden Fall ihre Quellen und
Du hast natürlich auch das Problem mit diesen Dingern, das ist halt irgendwie ein potentieller Müll. Den musst du irgendwohin loswerden und irgendwann hören die Leute auch auf, ihre Druckerpatronen in äh Mülltonnen zu schmeißen, also rennen sie in diese Läden rein, also das funktioniert wohl irgendwie ganz gut. Aber das ist natürlich dann das, was das
äh Business-Modell von Kanon, von äh HP, wie sie alle heißen, äh bisschen gefährdet hat, wenn jetzt einfach die Leute,
billige Dritttinte oder Dritttoner in ihre Drucker einspannen, mit denen sie ja eigentlich Kohle verdienen wollten, weil mit dem ursprünglichen Gerät verdienen sie ja keine Kohle.
Das heißt, ihr habt äh das und das ist schon eine fast also ich finde das wirklich faszinierend, ne, dieses also natürlichen Drucker verkaufst du einmal,
dann hast du das Problem, dass die gefälscht werden, ne? Und dann kommt doch der also diese diese.
Also die brauchten ja jetzt und darauf kommst du jetzt Fälschungssicherheit für Druckerpatronen.
Genau, das musste dann halt das musste dann halt passieren so, ne. Also man hat halt auch irgendwie diese komplette Chain übernommen und einfach sozusagen auch
die die äh Userexperience mehr kontrolliert, ja. Wahrscheinlich um den Nutzer da auch ein besseres,
Produkterlebnis zu geben, ne. Was dann auch darin gipfelt, dass ihr dann das Gerät selber sagt, wann's keinen Toner mehr hat und weil du wann du wieder überteuert einen Toner kaufen sollst, auch wenn's vielleicht noch nicht so weit ist.
Wer weiß?
Das sind alles nur Vermutungen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie dann äh so viel Druck bekommen von dieser Surd-Party-Welt. Dass sie das dann irgendwie so gedreht haben, dass sie dann in ihre Originalkartuschen so einen Chip eingebaut haben.
Der halt ein bisschen Krypto gemacht hat und der dann eben diesen
Gerät gesagt hat ich bin jetzt auch wirklich eine Originalkartusche von Kanon.
Wenn du den halt einsetzt, dann ist alles supi und wenn du mit zur Party-Kartuschen ankommst, dann kommt irgendwie,
Fehlermeldung, Error irgendwie falsches Gerät. Was hast du denn hier getan? So geht's ja nun gar nicht. Konnten sich dann aber auch nicht so richtig,
durchsetzen und das so komplett abschalten, weil sie dann gemerkt haben, dann kaufen ganz viele Leute auch unseren scheiß Drucker nicht mehr.
Fragten wir zu Krypto sagst ne ob da auch Blockchain Technologie drinsteckt in.
Geh mal zu den hin, noch verdienen die genug mit ihren Dingern, sagste komm Leute, wir machen's jetzt in der Blockchain und ah ja flippe das da schneiden wir raus, das machen wir, weil die Geschichte geht ja noch weiter.
Ja, so weit äh haben Sie das so und wir balanciert bekommen. Das heißt, wenn man so sein,
Partytoner da reinsetzt, dann geht das schon mal irgendwie. Dann musst du halt hier auf okay drücken und dann nochmal irgendwie runterscrollen und Pipapo und die Fehlermeldung ausblenden und dann druckt er auch und dann hast du's
billiger gehabt, aber so im Businesskontext äh kümmern sich halt viele Leute nicht drumherum. Die kaufen dann halt einfach bei Kanon irgendwie auf das äh festgelegte Budget dafür, kaufen die dann halt einfach original
tuschen und damit machen sie halt offensichtlich immer noch genug Geld.
Modell ist ja meistens so, dass sie äh dass das Unternehmen so Drucker fully service äh mieten. Das heißt, da kommt dann irgendjemand von Kanon vorbei und installiert dann da eine äh.
Oder so.
Würden einfach diese Drucker nicht mehr verkaufen, aber so richtig komplett zumachen für den Zweit-Party-Markt, das wäre dann halt auch unklug, weil dann skaliert irgendwie dieser ganze Markt nicht mehr so richtig,
Und ähm ja, so weit äh Stand der Dinge und dann kam äh Corona und mit Corona kam halt diese kompletten Verzerrungen in den Lieferketten, die wir bis heute noch haben und natürlich,
Mangel.
Irgendwie alle dann erstmal gesagt haben, oh ja, wir bestellen jetzt keine Chips mehr und dann so, ja okay, dann fahren wir halt die Produktion runter und dann so, ah nee, jetzt brauchen wir doch wieder ganz viele Chips, ja sorry, wir haben grad die Produktion runtergefahren. Was wollt ihr eigentlich? Bis ihr überhaupt noch was ihr wollt?
Haben halt viele Unternehmen Probleme genug äh,
äh ranzukriegen, um ihre Produkte zu verkaufen. Das betrifft die Automobilhersteller. Das betrifft eigentlich alle äh irgendwie und profitieren derzeit einfach alle nur die, die schon ordentlich vorbestellt haben und äh nicht ihre Bestellungen zurückgenommen haben.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall Canon hat äh nicht ausreichend vorbestellt und kriegt jetzt nicht genug Chips, um ihren komischen DHM-Chips da in ihre Kartuschen einzubauen und war jetzt gezwungen, ihre Originalka,
ohne diesen Gym zu ver,
Natürlich diese Drucker dann auch gesagt haben, was hast du denn hier reingesteckt? Das ist ja alles falsch.
Ja das.
Der der Toner.
Das geil!
Auswirkungen der Halbleiterknappheit auf die Verbrauchsmaterialien des MFP von Kanon, also MFP ist,
Multifunktionsprinter und äh erklären jetzt ausführlich, bei welchen welche Modelle davon äh betroffen sind und wo dann die Leute draufklicken sollen, damit
dann irgendwie dieser offizielle Toner trotzdem noch erkannt wird. Mit so schönen
der auf ihrem Gerät angezeigte Tonerstand ist möglicherweise nicht korrekt und der verbleibende Turnerstand kann plötzlich von 100 % auf 0 Prozent wechseln.
Also.
Wo kommt das denn her?
Kommt das wohl her?
Oh Mann, ist das das ist schon echt geil. Oh, das ist oh, das ist wirklich äh.
Vor allem.
Interim Toner.
Das ist oh Mann ist das das ist wie ab also so eine absurde Geschichte ja fälschungssicherheit für irgendwie ein bisschen Toner und dann dann hast du die oh ist das schön. Der finde ich super.
Ja, die sollten von der Pornoindustrie lernen, ja? Die hätten einfach Intimer rausgeben sollen. Das hätten die Leute einfach sofort gekauft.
Ja wozu brauche ich denn das? Na es ist einfach eigentlich so genauso wie vorher, aber ein Thema.
Für diskrete Dokumente. Gibt's den gibt's denn den Teamtoner?
Mhm. Jetzt auch neu als NFT.
Aber ne das das ist halt also das Problem ist ja, dass sie hier eine Hardware Security genutzt haben, ne. Wenn wir jetzt, nur mal so.
Mitm NFT, ne, dann hätten wir dann hätten wir dann hätten wir das Problem nicht. Dafür vielleicht ein anderes, aber vielleicht.
Unter Garantie.
Oh Mann. Okay, aber es ist.
Nicht so laut, sonst sonst machen die das wirklich.
Natürlich machen die das.
Ah das ist wirklich oh das wird ja die ganzen Tintenshop 24 äh freuen, wenn jetzt ähm
wenn jetzt bei den ganzen Canon-Druckern.
Aber die haben die dir auch teilweise gebrochen, diese Mechanismen und diese DM-Verfahren, die es da gibt. So wie's halt immer mit DRM irgendwie so der Fall ist. Es wird halt geht halt irgendwann kaputt,
kostet ganz viel Geld und und irgendwann wird's kaputt gemacht. Das war bei der DVD so, bei der Blu-Ray so, bei der Ultra-HD, Blu-Ray war's genauso. Bei HDCP war's genauso und das ist bei Toner natürlich auch nicht anders, ne?
Ja, aber dann machst du neue Tonerformen mit einem neuen DHM und sagst, wir haben jetzt hier die neue HP haste nicht gesehen, Print-Technologie.
Und äh sorgst dafür, dass alle einen neuen Drucker kaufen. Der ist ja noch günstiger als der Alte.
Schöne Wegwerf äh ja.
Ach schön, man es ist ihnen auf jeden Fall zu gönnen. Ich habe äh also ich habe auch einen Drucker für die Fälle, dass ich mal Papier drucken muss. Ich glaube, ich habe auch einmal in den letzten zehn Jahren musste ich einen neuen Toner kaufen. Ich habe einfach irgend so ein gefälscht, also ein was vor allem genau, man übernimmt ja dann auch
diese äh äh diese.
Theorien dazu, dass man jetzt sagt, ich habe einen gefälschten Toner. Nein, ich habe keinen gefälschten Torhüter. Ein Saturner. Mein Drucker druckt wieder eins, aber ich habe einen illegalen, gefälschten Toner. Huiuiuiuiui. Also es ist wirklich faszinierend
wie weit sich so etwas verfestigt, ne?
Ja.
Letzte Worte.
Gott.
Ich weiß.
Gibt jetzt nichts, was ich irgendwie äh akut äh loszuwerden hätte. Ich denke, die Sache ist so rund.
Dann bin ich glücklich.
Ich denke, ja ich denke du wirst äh sicherlich nochmal von uns aufgerufen äh werden, wenn du wieder mal irgendwas kaputtgespielt hast. Das äh scheint sie ja ganz gerne zu machen.
Macht Spaß, ja. Spaß am Gerät.
Ja halte ich nur bitte an unsere Sendungsfrequenz net. Also einmal die Wochen öfter nicht.
Nicht hier immer mit fünf und so, mhm.
Na die äh Regierung ist ja auch nicht so schnell irgendwie, was jetzt neue Blockchain-Projekte angeht. Und nicht alle,
direkt öffentlich zerlegt werden. Also ich meine es,
genug Sachen, die man erst mal so hinter äh verschlossener Tür mit einem BC bequatscht oder so, weil's halt sinnvoller ist und man auf dem Weg irgendwie mehr erreichen kann. Aber wenn halt hier irgendwie so so Steuergelder im Millionenhöhe irgendwie für so einen total
offensichtlich absurden Quatsch verbrannt werden, so der ist halt einfach drauftreten angesagt.
Das das ist dieses politische Lager. Das ist diese Zusammenrottung.
Na ja mit Hacking-Affinität.
Ja, danke für die Einladung.
Vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören. Äh an alle und ähm.
Hören uns nächste Woche wieder.
Genau, so machen wir das. Also tschüss.
Tschau.
Tschau, tschau.